squad members and many democrats were
protesting outside of supreme court for
abortion rights and they got arrested
and here's the best part aoc and ilhan
omar pretended they were handcuffed
it's a weird story i know that's why we
wanted to lead with it and talk about
what happened with this protest and the
arrest because they faked being
handcuffed probably for a photo op
we're also learning the much more
important stories that democrats are
pushing a bill to pack the supreme court
because they know they're losing they're
likely not going to win in november they
know they're likely not going to win in
november so they said okay it's time to
pack the supreme court take what power
we have and just force these things
through
now there's a lot of news going on today
we got that we got ron desantis
apparently is uh within range of trump
in the polling and things are starting
to uh to move really well for desantis
in terms of the presidency we'll see if
he actually is competitive with trump as
we move forward i mean we're still two
years out we are an eternity away from
the election but for some reason it's
just getting crazier and crazier and
then my favorite story here disney is
i'm sorry not disney uh netflix is
bleeding subscribers which is laughable
get well go broke
and disney has been surpassed by the
daily wires podcast network which is
also hilarious and i'm happy to hear it
so we got a lot of awesome stuff to talk
about before we get started my friends
head over to timcast.com become a member
to support our work because the big
announcement that i've been making uh in
every video now is that we have removed
paypal from our website
if you are a timcast.com member and you
use paypal you're fine you'll still be
able to log in and everything will be
normal every new member that signs up it
will default parallel economy which is
uh supported by dan bongino i believe
he's involved to his undergrad i don't
know exactly exactly his role he was one
of the creators one of the creators of
parallel economy is that what he is yeah
one of the founders wow well hey glad to
hear it and uh rumble's also involved
parallel economy is a censorship
resistant payment processor because we
mean it we've got a lot of stuff in the
works from making new shows to doing big
ad buys to expanding this platform
timcast.com to take the culture that
we're building the ideas that we have
the values we have and turning into
something very very massive and first
and foremost we said we don't want to
get banned and we don't want to support
companies that hate you and i giving
them money so they can facilitate this
service is a problem so we got rid of
them parallel economy right now when you
sign up at timcast.com you're supporting
us you're supporting parallel economies
efforts to displace paypal and other big
censorship platforms and rumble doing
similarly so i'm really excited that's
the case and of course as a member
you'll get access to our after hours
show tim cast uncensored on the front
page of the website every day or i
should say monday through thursday at
about 11 p.m we put those up
so support our work at tipcast.com don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and ladies and
gentlemen joining us tonight to talk
about all about all of this a couple of
guests first we have kian baxty hey
there tim how are you who are you uh
well i am a
reporter uh for the counter signal and
based out of canada and lately i've been
covering stories about energy security
food security and that sort of has all
culminated in the netherlands where
we're seeing this dutch uprising it's
just very similar to what brought me out
here last time when i came to talk about
the convoy
in ottawa they're doing very similar
stuff uh and and they are a rowdy bunch
of protesters uh so it was really
exciting to be there and
see the tactics that they were using
burning bales on the side of the road
like bail ieds and never seen anything
like it
do they like do they burst or something
yeah they they put
fireworks i guess in the middle of the
bales and as they bales burn down gets
the fireworks lights them off and then
loose hay just explodes it was crazy
that's crazy they're lying we gotta talk
about that for sure yeah for sure food
shortage stuff
yeah absolutely so that's what we've
been covering and uh happy to be here
right on we also got daniel turner uh
it's great to be back here daniel turner
power of the future daniel turner ptf on
all platforms powerthefuture.com the
organization's website and thanks for
having me on and john hale new hat for
you buddy he's my hat friend
who always asks me about my hats when
i'm on your show it's going to be a good
conversation a combination of
conversations uh farming food crisis
energy very interrelated and as we lead
with this abortion protest i just want
to point out the american people
according to gallup view economic issues
that 40 40 percent of americans think
it's the most pressing issue economic
issues are and abortion is at one
percent yeah and climate change was even
less in that new york times uh poll that
came out yesterday uh zero percent of
republicans zero percent of hispanics
zero percent of african americans
basically it was 42 year old brown
graduates with a degree in like poetry
that was all who cares
i would assume that it was like
middle-aged white women yeah
yeah we went to brown and studied poetry
oh yeah that's the ones who care about
climate change all right right on and of
course
hi everybody ian crossland here ian
crossland.net happy to be here let's
keep going yeah and i'm also here in the
corner happy to be here with these
two-headed gentlemen one from the u.s
one from canada so i am stoked we'll get
into uh see what trouble we can get up
to tonight this is a great story we're
starting out with right on everybody
let's jump to this first story we got
timcast.com breaking multiple members of
congress including aoc arrested over
pro-abortion demonstration outside
scotus take a look at their seer picture
why aoc's hands are behind her back
looks like she's being arrested well she
was arrested but she staged the the
handcuffs she faked it take a look at
this we have this daily mail circled it
she pretended to be handcuffed and you
know what daily mail says i love this
they're like
mock cops by pretending they've been
cuffed mock the cops what does that mean
why would the cops be mocked or care
about that at all no what they're doing
is people on twitter are seeing photos
of them with their hands behind their
back and they're going whoa they
handcuffed aoc they handcuffed ilhan
omar
people who are not paying attention will
just see photos on the news of them with
their hands behind their back as if they
were cuffed when they weren't for
dramatic effect and then aoc walks a few
feet and then like he's out of range of
the camera she does a big power fist or
whatever red salute or something like
that
you know it's just so fake when they
look back
like you see that picture of bernie
sanders getting pulled out of like he
was like civil rights activists getting
arrested on the street like it's real
chaos yeah and then they're gonna
juxtapose it with this and be like hey i
see faking being handcuffed looking back
no they think that in 20 years she's
going to show this photo back i thought
for abortion rights look at this picture
of me it's like when joe biden was
arrested in south africa for protesting
the right nestle mandela remember that
that's right at least he tells the story
there's no evidence
but he was arrested joe biden claims
he's been arrested like five or six
times and there's no documentation of it
anywhere but when every time he tells a
story he was arrested somewhere but you
know what i i gotta say everyone should
find themselves someone who loves them
as much as these folks love abortion oh
right like they love
people there was the whole talk about
how you know we're not pro-abortion
we're just pro-choice no y'all are you
all love abortion i thought you're gonna
say find someone who loves you as much
as these people love themselves that's
true that's who well that is abortion
though isn't it um but yeah these these
folks well you know and she has a
history of fake um
photo ops right i mean the the the white
pantsuit one at the detention facility
that turns out was a parking lot um is
that that's actually a fake like it's
just so hard to believe that someone
would do something so stupid but like
she went there and pretended to be
upset about something that wasn't
happening yeah or was let herself be
upset about what she was imagining in
front of her and brought her camera crew
so disturbed all the photos and and and
had
carefully chosen outfits because you go
to the desert wearing you know
white chanel pantsuits and and yeah the
whole thing was totally staged but it
worked right because as tim was saying
if you are a naive leftist and you think
she's a hero you just see those photos
and you say she's the best and now
they're gonna do the same with her
handcuffs you know maybe maybe i'm from
canada and i have a different angle on
this but it seems like that couldn't
have turned out worse for her because
now there's this meme going around where
whenever anyone's crying about like you
know they broke a nail
that's that's the picture is her cut out
white pants suit yeah crying about it
that was one phone look at these
pictures
she's like or terry the roller skater
from reno911 saying i was murdered right
that's the other that's the other one
for her it was an empty parking lot
and she's crying this one right here
she's just so awful yeah you know
when they write the history they could
either erase all the all the fake stuff
and be like remember when she was
protesting and got arrested and
handcuffed remember when she was crying
foreign they could do that and try and
manipulate the past but if it stays
transparent it's gonna just it just
looks so bad i think to be fair like
haven't you ever been at like a big
venue or something and parking's really
hard to find and there's a big fence and
the other side there's a ton of parking
spaces you know you can't park
you just break down you're like i want
to park my car i want vip parking oh no
like going to a going to a cubs game in
chicago and you got to find parking and
you're driving around you're driving
around you're like maybe sooner or later
someone's going to move and they don't
and then you just see that parking lot
with the fence all the way around it and
you just walk over in your white pants
suit and start crying
yeah i got to see the 34 members who
were arrested
aoc is clearly from new york ilhan
omar's from minnesota nothing in terms
of abortion law has changed in their
state so so you can do we got the list
here of the democrats who are arrested
you can decry like the national
right that you think was a race which
obviously is a falsehood but but for for
virginia where i am from for for
maryland for california most states
nothing has changed not only that for
many states now they're paying for
people to come to their state and have
an abortion so aoc should celebrate new
york is probably having more abortion
than it did before well here's here's
the uh the crazy thing that i'm thinking
of with this stuff is
if
texas says abortion's illegal
and a man says to the to like a men and
women you know hook up woman gets
pregnant where babies are made women is
eight and a half weeks pregnant i'm
sorry uh eight and a half months
pregnant and then says i'm gonna
terminate but i can do it in colorado
not in texas
so this is a viable baby able to survive
on its own and she flees the state
without telling anyone to go to colorado
to abort it because there's no
restrictions
this guy goes to texas and says help
she's kidnapped my child he's viable we
could we could deliver the baby she
doesn't need to kill it but she doesn't
want it so she's going to kill it the
interesting thing is
because we talk about this a lot if a
woman did that to a baby that was two
inches
forward out of her out of her womb but
the same gestational period she'd be
hunted down for kidnapping attempted
murder
but the same baby the same gestational
period in her womb she can drive out of
state to colorado to kill yeah
this is but this is crazy right now
because this is exactly how it is this
could happen right now in texas you
can't do it in colorado you can at eight
and a half weeks for any reason months
you said i'm sorry i said weeks ago
at like
almost to the point of birth colorado
has no restrictions
what would happen right now
if a woman did that if a woman took
who was pregnant and went to colorado
and said i don't care
a doctor could deliver the baby and get
out c-section or whatever but you're
like nah nope don't care if the doctor's
doing this in canada as well they're
calling for americans to come and try
abortion tourism you know help our
economy because he's destroyed it so
much and yeah you can come on come on up
and and in canada i don't know if you
know this but we have zero laws i guess
it's just this the colorado case
there's no law on it whatsoever nothing
on the book
books you can kill that child up until
uh it's it's breathing air which is
shocking to i think probably to a lot of
americans but it's shocking to me
does that happen
uh
there's definitely been cases of it yeah
especially where there's not a lot of um
especially out east um where there's not
a lot of
people uh
drawing attention to the to the tragedy
of it um you know in alberta where i'm
from there's there's a lot of
agencies that are willing to help young
mothers so that they can actually
deliver the child and and give it a good
life or even put it up for adoption if
that's what's require required but
out east a lot of those supports don't
exist because uh it's you know abortion
is second nature to eastern canadians
i gotta think i am not a i'm not an
attorney so those listening who are
gonna correct me i have to think if in
that scenario that you raised
it would be no different and i know a
baby is not drugs i know a baby is not
whatever i'm not i'm not trying to make
light of the pregnancy but i have to
think the rule would apply that if
there's a certain stage you can smoke
weed and some that you can't if i cross
the border and i smoke weed in that
state and i come back you can't say well
you did something wrong not in that
state i did if if you can take your kid
to uh uh uh a a a movie at you know nc
17 to one state opposed to another and i
take my state my kid to colorado and we
see a movie there we come back to texas
and they say that's illegal all in texas
is illegal but in colorado it's not i
have to think there would be nothing
done to the pregnant mother no because
what happened was what whatever
ultimately happened happened in a
different state and texas laws don't
have jurisdiction sure and the feds
would have to get involved and this is
where things get crazy so the woman goes
to colorado and she terminates the
pregnancy kills the baby texas says
that's an illegal illegal and she says
not in colorado colorado so what if
colorado said you're allowed to
literally kill a person that's all of a
sudden okay like the issue is
what would happen if the woman took
gave birth and then literally grabbed
the baby ran and got in the car and just
drove to colorado still like literally
after just delivering and she's you know
whatever like kind of messed up and hurt
or something and then gets to colorado
and then goes to an abortion doctor who
kills the baby like it's a murder right
so what does texas do if a person
kidnaps a child and murders it
what would texas do contact the feds and
what if the fed says we won't intervene
then what i honestly don't know
like what
what happens
they'd get away with it i mean uh
i'll just put it that way
there's uh people need to understand
this about crime in this country the
feds have a threshold i believe it's
literally called the threshold where if
a federal crime is committed but doesn't
reach a certain level they don't care
like a certain extremity of crime like
uh
the way was explained to me is
federal securities fraud in the amount
of 400
feds won't care about they're they're
not going to waste any resources over
something that's small they'll ignore it
but if you're somebody who's like life
savings was stolen by someone it was a
couple grand the feds probably will do
nothing
as long as it was interstate and the
states will be like we don't have
jurisdiction in that state sorry i can't
do anything about it if you illegally
register for a handgun
and you happen to be the president's son
feds don't care no exactly it doesn't
matter there's degrees and there's tears
that's how it works
so my my question is
colorado
uh
says it's illegal
i'm sorry texas says it's illegal
colorado says it's legal
that's a really weird circumstance
like it is a night and day difference in
morality imagine if indiana said you're
allowed to kill people have fun and
illinois said you're not so a woman took
her 12 year old child to indiana bashed
him over the head and then drove back to
illinois and said it wasn't illegal like
i'm pretty sure they're still going to
be like we don't care you murdered them
that's why we have federal laws saying
that murder is illegal no matter what
state
and you could argue that maybe there
should be federal laws about abortion
just right to make it easier but but
here's the issue what if the federal
government says we're not getting
involved we don't care then the states
could decide who where murder is legal
like a state could say you're allowed to
murder in our state i mean that was the
premise that's really what they're doing
according to conservatives colorado is
allowing limitless abortion at to the
point of birth
so like
i can't let's use canada as an example
like what if someone drives from
wisconsin into canada because there's no
limits and then like
as they're giving birth they kill the
baby
what is someone going to do
this is a really good example because
the selfie with them this is where there
is no international resolution because
it's two different countries if the
federal government says we side with
colorado because biden basically has and
we're not going to intervene i wonder at
what point does texas say
like we we need to be able to do
expeditions essentially to to extradite
people who kidnap people and murder them
dude if another state was doing
expeditions into my state i would fully
support the governor's removal from
power and some sort of military action
from your state from like if the state
went rogue and started invading and
attacking other states because of their
zealous beliefs i would fully support a
national and state you know multi-state
let me anyone expensive against them to
make them let me ask you this
someone uh someone kidnaps your
significant other
and then murders her
10 miles away across state lines
and what do you do
they become federal offense at that
point and the fed said we don't carry
and go well it's murder that's a
difficult we don't care go away i mean
well then just justice has failed at
that stage yes literally that's what's
happening right now it's not murder
points not literal murder it's it's
abortion's not murder okay well sheamus
thinks it is conservative you can think
things that aren't real it doesn't make
it real okay what's the penalty if you
aborted a child in texas now
that this has changed like what would be
the penalty oh i don't know
i think it's like trafficking abortion
or something like that yeah my point is
ian your morality is irrelevant to the
question of legality correct if in texas
they say it is illegal to do
and the people of texas agree with the
law that is illegal and amoral to do and
someone commits that crime somewhere
else and the feds don't get involved
what's the reaction going to be do we
let people from other states literally
kill our children that's their
perspective you might not agree with it
you're like not colorado's right they're
wrong well eventually someone's going to
grab a bunch of guns get on the back of
a motorcycle and drive in and they're
going to go stop it's not right it's not
right and wrong like you said it's not
morality issue it's a legal issue and uh
i guess it has no jurisdiction it is the
premise of of the famous dred scott case
i'm going to get the states confused but
the whole premise of dred scott which
was a terrible decision by the courts
was that
um
they they took this african-american guy
dred scott from a a free state to a
slave state and they were like well now
that you're in this state now you're a
slave and he was like no i'm not i'm
actually from
wisconsin they were like well you're in
missouri now and now you're a slave and
he's like but i'm not a slave and the
courts decided well you are the the
states the state's jurisdiction were
greater then it doesn't matter what in
illinois or wisconsin you were free
you're not free here dred scott said
that descendants of africa had no rights
to citizenship citizenship so it was way
worse than just well no but i mean like
but the premise of it was the this
person's this person's stature status
depended upon what state he lived in
yeah the states although the courts
ultimately decided that the states had
the jurisdiction to change his stature
of course it was a terrible decision but
it's the same about this unborn baby is
that does the baby's stature of life
viability of life does its it's personal
i depend upon the state maybe but that's
not what i'm bringing i don't think it's
relevant i'll ask you this ian do you
believe that sheamus thinks abortion is
murder
well he's told me he that he thinks it
is so i got to take him but his word
there all right okay so uh let's just
ignore the context around it and say
someone kidnapped sheamus child and is
trying to murder it what do you think he
would do to stop that murder from taking
place
i don't know this is this is this is
what i mean like i don't see an uh a a
like i don't see a good outcome
to the fact that you have
states
like where there are people who are
literally like it is murder and i will
not allow it louisiana tried to kind of
flex homicide but that's that's zealous
like it's not murder legally so for you
to say well i think it is like sorry
buddy you know take a take a lot take a
step in line like wait you know it's not
murder i'm looking at a political
politico article right now they say
texas has a trigger ban so anyone who
performs induces or attempts abortion is
guilty of a second-degree felony if the
fetus survives and first-degree felony
if not a first-degree felony is
punishable by life what's that what's
the what's the title of the statute like
what's the violation what's the criminal
violation
just says first degree felony i'm not
sure what that isn't i i'm not so i
guess the crime would be the crime of
abortion yeah
yeah which is after like 14 weeks i
don't know what texas number is but no i
think texas is period anyone who
performs induces or attempts abortion
which would be
i guess we have to look at under what
statute does it fall
because i'm curious if it falls under a
murder statute louisiana tried to codify
it as homicide they backed off so ian
when you say it's not murder well right
legally i would argue it doesn't fall
under homicide and they're trying to do
that regardless though
if
people don't care about the distinction
between the word murder and the word
abortion and they view it the same way
you saying it's not is completely
irrelevant to what the law of texas in
oklahoma it's just it sounds like an
argument towards post-modernism like
well if i believe it then that's my
truth and so that's real like sorry guys
in texas though it's obviously
considered a very serious crime and and
there's serious crimes that i would you
know i think a lot of people would go to
great lengths to prevent not just murder
yeah you know right dismemberment of a
limb or any sort of rape or abuse or
child abuse people would step in and
violently protect
i mean another another way to question
it is some states the age of consent is
16 in some states it's 18.
how do how do states handle it if a
person takes a 16 year old across state
lines to a state with a low age of
consent when you come back you go to
jail you get charged
now i guess the question is will
illinois do anything to go to indiana to
rescue the miner
if the feds won't
i have to i'd have to look into the into
the history of the law i wonder if
anybody knows
what this way uh a 16 year old who is a
minor in one state is taken by a 25 year
old to a neighboring state with a lower
age of consent and they say we're never
coming back what will that other state
do they're like not in this state it's
legal in your state it's not they're
like well you kidnapped a minor from our
state even though it's legal in that
state and that's that's possible like
some states actually have those
differences if the feds don't get
involved do you think the parents of the
16 year old are going to be like guess
our kids kidnapped yeah
or do you think they're going to be like
how in high water i am getting my kid
back if the kid actually got kidnapped
if the kid went of its own volition does
it have the authority miners can't
consent
so then it would be a federal crime if
someone took a 16 year old across the
feds said it's not a crime and that you
know we're not doing it we're not
involved if the fed said we will not
intervene do you think the people of the
state where the kid was taken from will
just sit back and be like well that
sucks or do you think they're gonna be
like please help me save my child they
were kidnapped
like i'm saying
these these circumstances could happen
in some capacity already they probably
will they may probably already have and
so i'm sure people will probably have a
bunch of
references they may bring up i'm
wondering like where we go here because
what's happening now is
illegal abortion and legal abortion are
so legally distinct
and like stark night and day in texas it
is a legal period in colorado there is
no restriction at all it is so
a different
that like
you've got a very serious crime that the
feds will not intervene in because
there's no federal statute on it so what
happens when a person
flees the state with the not with with
pregnant with a child of a man who
doesn't want the child to be killed
and then the child is killed in another
state that allows it
like
there's no federal involvement because
there's no federal statute so what
happens the person just can't come back
to texas well then is texas going to be
like well if people start fleeing the
state and killing the the children of
these men we will do nothing about it
you're going to get a
the system can't sustain itself in that
way it's just i don't know what happens
at that point
it's pretty raw i was kind of putting
myself in the mind of that guy like a
dad who's got an eight and a half month
old baby in gestation and the woman that
wants to bring the baby to term and
raise it the mom's like no i don't want
a baby to get dad's like well they're
divorcing maybe the guy's like i'll
raise it i want this is my son i want it
and the mom's like no i'm gonna go kill
it the guy has no no right to stop her
like grab her by the shoulder you know
you can't he might in texas they might
might i don't know if they have a right
to do it like legally prevent her from
committing a crime or something yeah
he calls the police leaving state lines
isn't a crime after that this is it's
this is crazy territory man it is
because imagine imagine the woman's not
going to get abortion and the guy is
just like you ain't leaving me so he
calls the police and says she's trying
to leave to get an abortion like a red
flag law right what do you i don't i
don't know how you deal with with this
with a circumstance
that's why that's why roe v wade i
thought was made sense is because you
can't leave it to the states to figure
out where where murder where killing is
going to be fine can i just walk over
there and kill him then if i can't do it
over here like that's why we had this
blanket rule of like no you just can't
or or yes you can no you can't but it
wasn't it wasn't the roe v wade was like
states can't decide within it's already
decided no within a certain amount of
time and then casey changed into
viability which made it nebulous which
resulted in a bunch of states having
different periods yeah so it was totally
different people would be like in my
state it's 11 weeks in your state it's
15 so i'll just drive across state lines
same problem
the over jobs resulted in them saying
you need to
codify at the federal level through
congress to figure this out which they
don't have so now we're in really
dangerous territory but let's let's
advance i don't want to keep harping on
this one issue because we've got others
take a look at this story that's also
rather depressing
house democrats tout bill to add four
seats to the supreme court oh boy this
is them just saying we can't win
politically we can't win your votes nuke
the system and give us the power and if
they actually try to overturn or bypass
the filibuster
to stack four more seats and give joe
biden
four appointees
man this country just implodes what do
you what do you think what do you guys
think will happen if let's say
in the next session or whatever
they say we're over we're doing away
with the filibuster
we're pushing this bill through it gets
pushed through and then joe biden goes
one two three four new supreme court
justices what do you think the reaction
would be yeah well this this is uh
theatrics because manchin and cinema
already said they would not tank the
filibuster they don't have the votes for
it and manchester and cinema both came
out and said they wouldn't uh allow
court packing so they know they don't
have the votes in the senate the house
doesn't have any jurisdiction in this
area right only the senate approves or
confirms justices
um so this is just this is desperate for
november to say hey vote for me because
i proposed a bill to add four justices
of the supreme court this is all
theatrics it's terrible the scenario
that you're painting is bad and we
shouldn't be playing these games it
reminds me of like playing with your
anyone you have a lot of brothers i was
the youngest of a whole bunch reminds me
of playing with your brothers as a kid
and when you're the baby and you keep
changing the rules because it's like not
fair you can only throw red ones and you
have to close your eyes and it's like by
the end the rules are so stupid but it's
basically because you're a loser and you
don't want to lose you want to prolong
the game and that's what they're doing
they just keep changing the rules to
prolong the game i i suppose it's fair
to say obviously it'll never happen you
know yeah but we didn't think roe v wade
was going to get overturned either and
that's well some some people did yeah
but most people didn't
ruth bader ginsburg was one she thought
it would be overturned eventually there
were a lot of conservatives they were
like there's no way they'll do it they
won't do it it's it's they didn't some
people thought it was gonna happen but
most people didn't i mean i
maybe we had conversations but i thought
the attitude most people had was like
man i don't know i don't like i don't
think they'll have a spine for it
roberts will be opposed to it and and
then it happened and i didn't i think it
was gonna happen but i will say at the
very least the bare minimum is we're at
the point where democrats are just
basically saying torch the system and
give us the power regardless of if
they're able to get it or not and so
if we keep moving in this direction it's
only a matter of time before
it spills over
and then there's there's i mean i got to
be honest i already think we're in the
territory of
you know it's just about seizing power
regardless of what matters for the
american people yeah and what's
frustrating about this is that
roe is a clearly very dramatic decision
it's got a lot of impact i'm not at all
making light of it but there have been a
lot of supreme court cases which are
have way more impact on the average
american without them realizing it that
were decided poorly kilo versus new
london is one that always comes to my
mind which was about imminent domain
right and the right for the the
government to seize your property for
the promise of of additional taxes that
if you go to times square in new york
right now you'll see all these signs
because the governor of of the state and
the mayor want to take over about 300
businesses around penn station because
they want to build a new 15 comp
building complex and they're like well
this is my little pizzeria and it's like
well we're going to take it because of
imminent domain and they legally have
the right because of kilo versus new
london it happens all the time eminent
domain is how government seizes your
property because
tim wants to build a condo there and the
condo will generate more taxes than your
little farm that's great
a terrible decision so my point is the
the courts have made terrible decisions
in the past threat scott was one of the
terrible decisions uh koromatsu was one
of the terrible decisions but we we've
never responded with well therefore we
have to blow up the courts so it's just
it shows you not just the pettiness of
the left right now but it shows you the
real ignorance of them right politics is
a slug match and sometimes you win and
sometimes you lose and the system
prevails for 246 years but the fact that
they're like well now we don't want to
play the game anymore it's cultural
decay it really is and how do you how do
you repair that how do you how do you i
don't know if you can take back control
of the money system that's a good start
like you said at the beginning of the
show 40 percent of people think the
economy is the biggest problem whereas
one percent thinks it's abortions hero
percent what was the other one we're
talking about climate change zero
percent
but how many people are are going to try
and nuke the system for the economy well
i don't want to nuke it i just want to
fix it no no i'm not saying you do i'm
saying there are people who are looking
at abortion and maybe one percent but
those are people who are willing to
throw fireballs
yeah
yeah don't put don't put power in the
hands of radicals right now
yeah well there might be a time and a
place for it but uh not over what's
happening we need to focus on the
economy aoc 13 million followers and
she's growing and she's with that fake
handcuff thing
it's clearly she's just trying to
manipulate people for power
she pretended to be handcuffed yeah
photo op things like if she can get
enough people behind her believing in
her then she can do the right thing
right thing
yeah subversion to get people on my side
and then i'll do the one thing i've
agreed up a greater agree on her with
was when she said some someone police
maybe open the doors from the inside
yeah but she's only saying that because
it personally impacts her yeah i'm
saying because i care about what happens
to the rest to this country what happens
to the people she wants to legalize
psilocybin and mdma for study and that's
probably because i mean she likes it
it's the whole premise of that great
show ozark spoiler alert i apologize but
the whole thing is like we're going to
do all these evil things because
ultimately we'll do good with it right
and we just do evil thing after evil
thing but like one day or it's the
premise of the godfather right one day
we'll be legitimate so in the meantime
i'm going to kill all of these people
but in the end and i think that's
sometimes how they think they'll
ultimately when i have everything i need
all the power all the wealth i will do
good but to get there i'm just going to
have to kill several people or i'm going
to have to do fake photo shoots or bomb
the system but does it like yeah we talk
about our fake photo shoots
and people just believe it yeah they
just keep believing it she keeps doing
it they keep believing it yeah
i don't know man the funny thing is is
that
members of the house besides the speaker
i mean they're really not very
significant no offense to them but like
anyone who's worked in dc and the polit
like one member of congress and and
they're not supposed to be right they're
not supposed to be powerful that's the
problem heck you began the the broadcast
by saying you know 2024
we which it's a long ways away and we're
already talking about it we're already
talking about it because everyone knows
how damn powerful the president is
that's why i disagree with you one row i
don't want power in dc i want power in
the states i want way more influence of
my governor and my mayor
because i can i can have impact on that
heck i could run into the mayor of this
town walking down the street but you're
never going to run into the member of
congress it's actually kind of a joke
right you know and you're never going to
run into the president
we shouldn't want these powerful aoc
shouldn't be powerful and the fact that
she's like but i want power to do good
whoa that's actually what's the
foundation
well in her mind good no i don't think
so i don't think she thinks she just
wants power yeah i don't think she
thinks to herself like i'm a good guy at
all i don't think she thinks that much
possible i think she's just like more
followers well she is the prime example
of using the ends to justify the means
and i think based on her photo ops we
can really see and based on the amount
of power that she has like she's a super
social justice uh political figure and
she's not using that power for good like
she had a small amount of power and
she's not doing good with it i see no
reason to believe that if she was given
a greater deal of power that she would
do anything different with it
i don't know though i guess she could
change her tune but i have yet to see
people really make introspect changes
like that on this speaker well if i was
kirsten gillibrand who's the senator
from new york which is the next high
powerful position i would be very much
afraid remember she ran for president in
16 remember she had the pride t-shirt
and there was that does that mean
exactly there's the meme of her
pretending that she's really big on
these issues she got crushed in the in
the primary
um but she's done nothing since it's
been
six years i mean she's in she's a
non-entity in the in the senate and if
you're kirsten gillibrand you should be
petrified to think aoc does have 14
million followers and we're talking
about her and i don't did you ever hear
kirsten gillibrand's name even before
you've heard it you've heard of aoc yeah
absolutely so i mean she's going to keep
climbing but i just hope she climbs only
within that hellhole i used to call home
which is new york
wow no offense i think she'll love you i
think colbert asked her if she's going
to run for president is she old enough
to run for president she will be she
will be she will be
35. so she could run because by the time
the election like a month before the
election she would be 35. so she could
be campaigning all day and night i think
what would would happen and maybe
someone will tell her that politely
is she would have huge momentum
but ultimately in the presidential you
got to start talking and you and she
would she would embarrass herself so
because she's really not very smart i
think she should do it she'll she'll she
will i think she maybe someone her
advisors will tell her her flame will go
out so poorly it's like kirsten
gillibrand or like all although kamal
harris became the vice president her own
state didn't vote for her because she
was so bad in the debate yeah right um
so
you can run for president but you will
expose yourself when people critically
ask themselves like
who's qualified to be president of the
united states it's not going to be a
bartender you know like i appreciate the
work that bartenders do i really do but
when when people when moms and dads are
going to the ballot box and saying who
do i trust do i trust an accountant or
do i trust a bartender to run this
country they're going to pick the
accountant yep
yeah or or someone who at least has a
deep understanding of of the country and
a deep appreciation of it and the thing
i dislike about her which i just like
about the the modern left right now as a
whole is they have genuine disdain for
this country you know they don't they
don't like the country they think the
country is racist sexist whatever they
don't celebrate they don't have red
white and blue right like that new
yorker article yeah they don't
they don't celebrate what america is
they think america needs to be deep
totally transformed you know what i love
i i love that
they hate this country it's racist white
supremacist evil
fascist homophobic but they desperately
want more people to suffer along with
them coming across the southern border
the left's motto misery loves company we
hate this place so you should come here
is that it you're so right about them
hating the country though in canada it's
the same thing um if you see someone
flying a canadian flag you know they're
a conservative right which is like what
like here i don't know if it's the same
is it it is exactly just if you fly an
american flag you're uh right it's the
same in the uk as well it seems like
everywhere throughout the west there's
this mindset that oh we hate this
because we've never known anything else
we've never actually known suffering or
struggle we've never lived in russia
we've never lived in you know any of
these small countries that are really
fighting like myanmar like we haven't
seen it and we're just like ah it's
gross well it's still maga month so
that's true that's true you have that
american flag as your profile picture it
is that's why it was so funny to see
prince harry uh today at the u.n larp as
an american
exactly talking about how we've
sacrificed our country democracy's under
threat and you want to say
sixth grades great great great great
great great grandfather
caused all this to begin with right if
he weren't a bad guy we probably would
still be part of you so it's direct line
to your six-pack great-grandfather that
we're here to begin with so just shut up
harry honestly you know i mean quite
shut up megan that's not harriet
i'm kind of like i'm i'm i don't like
crapping on these people at prince harry
aoc because i feel like they're
massively influential and powerful and
if we don't work with them
the entire system is going to get
smeared
is he powerful though i looked at a
picture of the united nations when harry
was talking and it was empty
i don't think people actually think that
this guy's an intelligent
thoughtful person i think they think
he's someone that goes on oprah and yeah
can get clicks but
when serious people need to listen they
don't yeah he's just uh he's like he he
walked away from the royal family so
it's he's an example of like freedom
over power kind of person
i don't know if he's a freedom over
power person because he still seems to
let me fix my camera a little bit we're
getting daniel's hat there we go he
still seems to really want a lot of that
power that he willingly gave up by
leaving the royal family and his wife is
was an actress in america so i feel like
they were
trying to be like princess diana or
something i think that's what was going
on there very well i think i think ian
has a plan to try and reconnect to the
crown and
the revolution i think this is i want
canada off the british monarchs
let's do it how do we start i think this
is the big mystery
oh my gosh i yeah no i think that if we
if we just drop tradition i mean i
respect your guys's decisions as
freedom-loving americans to leave i get
it but
part of me you know if you don't if you
don't value that tradition and you know
like the queen back then when you guys
left there's a reason why you did it but
now the queen doesn't have any
strong political power especially not
the governor general that's the head of
state of canada
so you know just getting rid of it is
just playing into the leftist hands who
want to destroy everything that that
attaches us to our past i don't i don't
know if i agree she has no power i mean
jesus doesn't use it perhaps and so you
might just think she's not using it as
well she might be on the phone call with
trudeau and she'll be like do it and he
goes yes ma'am there's something in that
red box that she gets every day right
she's looking at something
so
the the uk was facing uh an uprising i
remember was like 1800s or whatever so
they created the house of commons i'm
not big on british history and so like
if you're a monarch and you're an
absolute ruler and people are screaming
off with their head what's the smart way
to deal with it
you say okay here's what we're going to
do we're going to tell them we're going
to give them power and share it and be
democratic and in parliament all that
stuff and create the house of commons
and y'all will just do as you're told or
will kill you and then what happens is
the people are like yeah we won and the
queen just keeps her mouth shut as she
rules from the shadows
the house of commons was 1341. i was
wrong about that i think that was king
john now i could be wrong about that but
maybe it was the 13th richard was after
king john after king john but king john
signed the magna carta which was
basically saying yeah
you have the king has to have some rules
um and then ev every monarch from king
john down has ceded an amount of power
one way or another from either letting
parliament exist to
not fighting a war against his own
parliament or and then you get to where
it is now but you know i'm not saying
that you're wrong um what if the
conspiracy is the queen is secretly the
queen
there's a lot of there's a lot of
active investigations into what what
sort of power she exerts over the
british parliament i don't i don't think
that that really extends much to canada
at the time but um you know a lot of her
influence she doesn't ever not sign a
bill that's put on her desk but her
staff are routinely reaching out to
government as bills are being
put forward and
offering their advice and their advice
is often like canada uh no the british
british parliament uh they're much more
interested in that i don't think she
gives canada much of a thought i bet she
does
i'm sure she's deep down the queen is
the queen the uh it's british columbia
like the idea is like we know she's a
queen but we just don't think she does
anything and it's like but like why do
you really think that you know like
it's not that far-fetched to think the
queen actually just makes a phone call
and says hey we're doing this you just
you should do this too and they say okay
yeah you know i mean it's her majesty's
prisons it's her majesty's armed forces
right ships it's hers
that's all hers
which is pretty cool
i'm glad we don't have her don't get me
wrong i think she's a lovely woman from
a distance yeah although what happens
all the commonwealth countries are woke
yeah i think she's i really think she's
great i think she's done a a great job
over the course of 70 years or whatever
it's been but i'm really fearful what
what comes after her what what happens
with prince charles what happened i i
like prince william a little bit more
than prince charles but prince charles
is like right up right up there with the
rest of the world economic forum and
yeah
i don't know if you want to get into
that i often tweet photos of charles's
many properties and the ones he will
inherit because also he cares deeply
about the climate issue
and it's wonderful to care about climate
change from like your 30 000 acre estate
with with servants and he's like oh this
whole garden is organic it's like
yesterday well that's foreign
i don't care what we're talking about
we're talking about prince charles
inheriting the the empire of britain as
if it's okay it's not okay for a person
to own that spoken like a true america
sounds like it let's talk about uh let's
talk about some good news that involves
the royal family let's do it we have a
story from the daily mail has to do with
meghan markle a little bit
will going woke make netflix broke
streaming giant could see shares slump
further after losing 970 000 subscribers
as it was blasted over canned meghan
markle cartoon and transgender pregnancy
comedy
what oh weird well okay well here's the
good news i mean that i guess get will
go broke jeremy boring of the daily wire
tweets daily wire just surpassed disney
to become the sixth largest podcast
publisher in the country per pod track
that's awesome disney has a 100 year
head start on us it won't be enough as
the years roll on and their war on their
own audience continues
this is one of the biggest
get woke go brokes yet did you know that
netflix predicted they would lose two
million subscribers and they didn't so
good for them but they already know
they're going to be going broke i don't
know if it's because from the meghan
markle fallout i don't know i think it's
probably because um stranger things
ended too oh so is that bad is that an
organic ad that is a real a real netflix
show
about a man who gets pregnant yeah it's
weird as they do but everyone was like
freaking out like they made a woke movie
and i'm like bro junior wasn't woke
remember junior with arnold
oh yeah he gets pregnant oh good lord
like did you watch the trailer for this
it's not about being transgender it's
about a guy who gets pregnant it's like
junior part two or like a reboot or
something so what's the what's the plot
there he like finds out he got pregnant
they're like well we don't know how it
happened but it did he's like oh no and
then it's a guy who's pregnant oh where
does the baby come out no i think they
mentioned that in the movie no his ass
or something oh gosh that's great
i'm pretty sure you would die it's like
kindergarten yeah but look look look
disney definitely get won't go broke
they wanted to play the groomer game
they can win it yeah now daily mail i'm
sorry daily wire is bigger that's kind
of crazy if you think about it the daily
wire is only what seven years old yeah
very young like seven decade i think
yeah it's kind of crazy that's
remarkable
here's what i see happening with the
daily wire netflix disney
these big companies
stood atop this massive shining hill
and everybody looked up at the shining
people on the shining hill and said i
longed to be a top there with you
and then one day people started walking
off the hill
while screaming about weird stuff that
made no sense
daily wire was like guys we can just
walk up
like we they're leaving we'll walk right
up yeah they walked right up and now
they're standing there and they're like
wow look at that we're just yeah these
people like walt disney spent his whole
life walking up the hill grinding
getting to the top and then once he's
there okay now he's like all right son
would you like to take a helicopter up
here with me so and the kids now the
kids that never had to climb the
mountain or on the top of the mountain
they don't understand the struggle and
people like ben shapiro and jeremy
boring have climbed the mountain to get
there those are the people we want on
top of the mountain that know how to
climb a mountain the mountain right and
the rest of it's just a skin suit it's a
corporate skin and it's the same as we
were just talking about some of these
politicians in the aocs there isn't a
lot of respect for the the patrimony for
the what was built before i arrived i
forget the name of the current ceo of
disney but he arrived with a hundred
years of this that other people built
and all you have to do in terms of idea
of patrimony and custody is you have to
hold it cherish it grain to try to
expand it but don't destroy it and and
since they didn't have to climb that
mountain to use the analogy since they
didn't have to work hard to become
members of congress they don't have a
love for it they don't have a risk but
they don't have an awe of it so they
think it's easy to just destroy it the
supreme court destroy put transgender
cartoons on for five-year-olds and it's
like wait a second this isn't yours
you're just the custodian of it but nope
i'm gonna destroy it maybe it's just as
simple i mean people don't want to work
for someone else's project they want to
make their own yeah or they're making
their own all right but well so they're
destroying someone else's in the process
we entered this era of meritocracy with
the internet where people could make
their own channels one of the things we
often run into with hiring is that it's
like oh hey we need this job
and we need someone who's good at it and
it's really hard to find someone who's
good at it because anyone who is good at
it starts their own company instead of
working for someone else's
so like we're in that era of meritocracy
the internet has democratized the
process by which people can contract get
hired or make their own thing so who's
left to work at disney
woke weirdos nobody wants that meanwhile
people are launching their own projects
starting their own youtube channels or
at least trying to do something yeah we
talked about maker studios before the
show i was involved with these people um
lisa nova ben donovan dan zapinski like
on
make we had the station 2007 youtube all
these really popular phil defranco dave
days we all came together to form this
like internet union of people which was
make which was uh the station then
became maker studios when it became a
company then disney bought maker for a
billion dollars and they thought they
were getting all the talent all the
people that had been working through
maker but when they bought maker all
those people were like yeah you don't i
they left and then they realized we have
the name maker studios but we don't have
the talent that made maker studios great
this is the funny thing like there's
things on youtube called multi-channel
networks which are mostly defunct these
days
and they'd be like sign with us
and we can get commercials put on your
video so you make money and we get a
percentage of it and then you'd be like
okay well i already have ads on my
videos why should i sign with you and
they say we'll protect you we can talk
with youtube it's a real advantage
and it'll be like x amount of time they
have no control over your content they
can't make you produce content that you
you're not signed to them with
obligations on producing records or
videos or anything like that it's just
literally let us wrap your ad sales for
you
disney buys it i remember when i was
working at fusion there were people who
genuinely thought they were like
when uh we're gonna walk we're into this
new project why don't we pull up our our
maker talent pool and i'm like what does
that mean and they were like they pulled
this pdf showing all of these youtubers
on maker and they're like we can get any
one of these people and i was like
sure you can get literally any actor you
want you want to get brad pitt just pay
him and they're like what do you mean
and i'm like these people don't work for
you you bought nothing you bought the
rights to sell ads in their content and
you don't sell ads you're a production
house
and they were like you mean we can't get
these people to be in our shows i'm like
well yeah if you ask him and pay him but
at that point you might as well ask brad
pitt or tom cruise and they were like
huh they genuinely thought buying the
network was like
buying buying a record label yeah like
the record like you were signed to this
record label you have to produce two
albums we want this album no like they
could quit at any moment you had no
rights over any of it so these companies
have been completely insane from the
get-go and i think the big issue for the
most part is
two two things one they think wokeness
works because they don't care
and merit is driving people of real
talent away yeah i mean who why would
someone want to work for netflix
no and i wonder good at it and and how
many of these people have hired you know
all of the woke
hr reps and the woke vice president of
of what's the acronym for
diversity inclusion
the ie is that what it is right that if
you're the ceo you just hear these
people yammer at you all day all day all
day this is what we have to do and
ultimately you cave but you know what
what's going to change them is stock
prices look at you know we were right
before the show and on we were looking
at disney stock i remember where it was
where it went up to where it is now
i mean it's down almost almost 50
percent that that has to tell boards of
directors to say i don't care about your
you know if you think transgender
66.25 year-to-date if you think
transgenderism is the most important
thing going the markets clearly show
something else and so you've you've got
to go because i don't care about
transgender i'm saying this if i'm a
board member i don't care about trans i
don't care about any of this crap i care
about making money and right now you are
not making us money so you have to go
but daily wire is making money so i want
to know why they're making and why we're
not ultimately that's what the board is
going to be pushing here's what it is i
had i had a friend who played in the
band once i have a friend who plays in a
band i you know don't talk to a lot of
my old friends anymore but uh they
played like weird experimental music
and they were like we're gonna make it
big man because this is the future and i
was like dude no it isn't i was like i
understand the idea of doing
experimental music hoping you find
something new that becomes popular but
like pop music is pretty cut and dry as
to why people like it i was like look
right now
you're trying to sell a product to
people right you want to come buy it so
what's someone going to buy your
experimental new spinach
and cheese ice cream
or chocolate
and they're like well spinach and cheese
is gross and i'm like maybe have you
ever tried it no okay well maybe it's
not gross you don't know you never tried
it how about matcha green tea
hey in japan they got a ton of that
stuff you've never tried it you might
you don't know if you'll like it or not
sounds weird though right it's
disgusting exactly you don't like it so
i said why don't you guys
if you want to be big and famous if
that's your goal why don't you make a
product you know people will like now
you want to do something new and unique
so you're not just making chocolate ice
cream you're making like chocolate with
salted caramel like something it's a
little different like salt in your ice
cream yeah but try it it is pretty good
yeah this is what netflix is at right
now so what happens is you got an ice
cream company that makes delicious
cookie dough ice cream and everybody
wants to buy it but cookie dough ice
cream is making people fat so along
comes these young people who are like
you're making people fat young people
don't like that what they like is fresh
vegetables you should make our esg ice
cream zucchini cucumber
zucchini cucumber surprise
it's the right ice cream to have and
then all of a sudden no one's buying it
but don't worry you're not you're not
actually correct but you are morally
correct and the company implodes and
then what happens is the daily wire
comes along and they start selling
chocolate ice cream again because these
people decided not to you can't just
think we're gonna do this esg stuff and
it's gonna work because we are on top no
yo there's two mountains there's esg
which is a pile of garbage and then
there's everest and you're like well if
we're on a pile of garbage we're still
on top yeah sure on a pile of garbage so
go for it leave the mountain behind
leave room for for timcast.com for daily
wire for other channels to start rising
because you've walked away from it
that's what they're doing yeah in the
name of vsg and another it really was in
the 90s you remember probably as
similarly they decided what people were
going to like next it was the the
marketing companies nbc disney cbs they
were like okay what's the next big thing
frizzy hair and hairspray whatever now
it's people are it's democratized i
guess is a way to put it and they don't
you can't keep controlling the mind it
doesn't work anymore people are free
their minds are free now people are just
it's become much more apparent
what works and what doesn't but in your
ice cream scenario which is what disney
is the company implodes because no one
wants their esg ice cream
but they still have production
facilities ice cream making machine
distribution networks that have value so
someone will swoop in and take it i'm
saying when it comes to disney their
theme parks have value their studios
have value someone's gonna swoop in and
be like this we can't lose the value of
these things because you're running a
crappy product i know
you at home and maybe all of you here
have been driving down the street one
day and have seen an auto insurance
company in a building that looks
suspicious suspiciously like a taco bell
you've seen those right or a pizza hut
and it'll be like you know family
insurance center and you're like that's
a pizza hut
because at some point the pizza went out
of business yeah but there was a
building there and someone was like we
can use it we'll take it cheaper than
building one uh you you see all over
chicago you see like it's it's obviously
a taco bell but it was turned into
something else and you're like i was
kind of funny that's what we're going to
see with disney yeah they got the ice
cream machines yeah but they're just
cranking out broccoli and and cheese
ice cream i mean broccoli and cheese is
good but as ice cream i don't know right
but they're also pumping out broccoli
and cheese ice cream but it says
chocolate on the label right like thor
is it it's not that all these marble
matters are like you can call it
whatever but it's just a crappy well
like a jump that's a little too much
like thor
movie was weird but it was thor but it
was like kind of not thor because they
just made it wacky and wild
and it was like
sorbet with the colors yeah they could
have called him gore and made him have
like a an orange or was the bad guy oh
okay then laura you could have called
him lore and it would have been like a
silver helmet well it's a stupid suit so
disney's got the facilities to produce
all this stuff
when eventually they go out of business
like blockbuster
all those machines will be lying around
and people be like how much for that 10
000 camera 20 bucks i'll take it well
there is some great uh statistic i'm
sure we can pull it up but of the 100
top companies in the year 1900 i think
only one or two are still around wow so
so companies do rise and fall right i
mean standard oil is gone uh you know
general electric isn't it's still around
but it's not one of the top 100 yeah but
i bet it's like they all consolidate
into one that's what's happening with
the banks they're consolidating yeah it
was all steel not crazy so disney
probably you know i mean odds are it's
not gonna last a hundred years i think
it'll get bought by blackrock
yeah everything will be bought by black
i wonder if blackrock's gonna buy an
entertainment the the dutch farmers are
being bought right now by blackrock
what's that story
we should talk about they're trying to
buy them we should talk i mean some of
these are still around what uh standard
oil westinghouse ford union carbide
general electric uh general electric
dupont standard oil at t standard oil
you said twice
but they're not sold like the top 100 oh
yeah it's in there twice it is
standard oil nj standard oil and why oh
different new jersey new york standard
oil is rockefeller's oil company that
got broke up it was basically the first
multi like a monopoly
court case where they developed
antitrust to stop rockefeller all the
top companies are manufacturing in
resources
we sent that all to china that's right
thank goodness it'll be weird like uh
and they're they're not american either
which is a little bit confusing monsanto
got bought by bear bears motors
sears they have sears on this list but i
think it's unfair to say they still
exist because i think they do basically
dao how why you know that company dao
yeah
and they call it the dao industrial
average as if dao the company has some
sort of influence
yeah dow jones but this is just the same
isn't that just the same or something i
guess i would think it's not look it up
yeah i'm curious yeah
it's the same corporate name and dao is
like they make high fructose i mean they
make like
i think you need to google that before
you say something like that because you
maybe just be wrong yeah they might just
be sometimes happening to be a happy
coincidence oh yeah you never know like
just because my name's tim pool doesn't
mean i'm anything to do with him but i
did change my name to tim pool by the
way well that's what cracks me up about
when you find like this healthy
bar made by this company which is owned
by coca-cola which is owned by and it's
like so it's really not like this i mean
maybe the bar itself is healthy when
you're like this is some local organic
it's like nah it's not it's all made in
the factory
dow jones or more precisely dow jones
and company is one of the world's
largest business and financial news
companies yeah this is dow jones
industrial average it's the same thing
so charles dow dow jones so he basically
has co-opted the industrial
the economy by creating this industrial
average nonsense and naming it after his
own corporation
dow's
yes no no he's not herbert henry dao
created dow chemical and charles dowd
created the dow jones
are they brothers they may be cousins
maybe uh same person though maybe they
were secretly married and no one knew
about it yeah what were they like on her
brother
henry dow you say one of the guys names
henry yeah henry dow and then the other
guy all i know is that they all used to
own great mansions they're from very
different places so i don't think
they're related one's from canada and uh
belleville canada west
and charles dallas from sterling i don't
know are you related to the guy i don't
know what i was going to say
it might be fake news
i would have met him it's nice when you
can like
divest your responsibility by having
like a distant family member do it for
you or your son yeah you know
joe biden hunter biden this is growing
into quite the conspiracy that's great
just go with it herbert henry down
charles dao yeah how far back does he go
let's talk about this story oh the story
is crazy yeah so dumb family of girls
seemingly snubbed at sesame place
higher's lawyer considers a lawsuit
what so it's a slow news day and the
country's collapsing so how about this
story
rosita is that the name of the weird
stupid muppet rosita
rosita was walking past two little black
girls who waved and reached out their
arms and rosita waved no
and then everyone erupted on twitter
like ben crump didn't he tweet like
you're racist or something so yeah
everybody was tweeting about it part of
me right now wants to just like turn
this off and go play spelunky or
something
this is we live in such a stupid stupid
place
it is entertaining yeah i like it at
first i was like that seems kind of rude
why didn't you do that but then i was
looking at what she did before she did
the same thing to someone else she was
like she put here let's play the video
don't give her it here's the thing did
she not touch children or something just
give hugs she's hurt so look they're
like we want hugs she's giving high
fives late yeah no no no no no
no no no no
so the woke
crowd is now moving for those little
girls do you see your face i mean she
should have high fived or it should have
hurt her face she's like one of the hug
but they don't hug children they don't
have anybody yeah because they'll get
sued if they get if they hug
like watching oh it's them a parade yeah
and then everyone would want to hug and
you can't stop yeah you can't stop you
know you get your diseases from covet or
whatever but cooties i feel bad like
they just wanted a hug it's kind of sad
but they went went nuts saying it was
racist
this is so crazy man this is where we're
at right now
where's you know we need we need norm
mcdonald back yeah he's great i'm just
kidding we just need his commentary and
everything does he be like what
well do large green monsters have racial
bias towards young black girls i didn't
i don't know like what they do i don't
have a lot of familiarity with what is
rosita what is it no idea is it a bear
it's a puppet it's a puppet oh wait then
she says she hugged the little white
girl next to us
when i complained he looked at me like
i'm crazy
so is that it i wouldn't need to see
evidence yeah
pixar didn't yeah sesame place said the
performer wearing the rosita costume
gestured no several times in the video
not at the children but rather in
response to multiple requests for
someone in the crowd who asked rosita to
hold their child for a photo which is
not permitted
that's not what it looks like
yeah go back she says uh no she shakes
her oh that's right she the head looks
down and the mouth is where the eyes are
right i think so i don't know he's
saying no to the kids they're lying
that's sad yeah i don't know maybe it's
sad but like you can't see on video
the rosita hugging a white kid or
whatever but i don't know maybe that
happened i think that's on hunter
biden's laptop video
yeah we should get into it for sure i
have long suspected sesame street of
being overtly racist and this just
confirms what we've already known that
muppet monsters just plain don't like
brown people and that's that's wrong i
mean the whole premise of sesame street
from the beginning was multi-rich like
literally like from like when it was
started in like 72 or something was what
made it so groundbreaking is that like
in the first of all it took place like
in
the bronx on a stoop right or like in
brooklyn and it was in an urban area and
everyone was multiracial from like the
very first episode remember when they
did the first homeless muppet oh yeah
and then everyone was like yo oscar the
grouch would be living in a trash can
yeah
no that trash can counts as a house yeah
i don't know man this is this is just
the the absurdity that we live in it's
like you see these videos that video to
portland where the the two people are
fighting outside of their cars and the
white woman's like you're mad about your
oppression you're not mad at me and he's
like what get out of my face you
her
and i'm just like yeah
that's amazing i'm here for it
i'm watching them fight with each other
it's fun but it kind of feels like we've
been yuri besmanov you know what i mean
they've planted the seeds of discord and
now people of fractured psyches are
fighting with each other over their
nonsense yeah
well then you have to ask the question
would this have happened anyway is this
like a result of human nature i
personally think it's a result of having
too much free time too much money and
these are like blessings have been taken
to an extreme like now we have nothing
to do we're bored we have no way to feel
special other than being victims which
is like a terrible place for a society
to be in and uh we're just too lucky for
our own good we celebrate victimhood we
do yeah that's why they're they're
trying to sue this little green monster
that's so dumb and and they're clearly
just looking for victimhood they lack it
and they want it to be because of race
they have nothing else which is really
sad it is it is and i agree with you
this this comes as the result of not
having real
problems in your life it's a lot like
again climate change yeah right like
these are the these are the causes of
privilege if the worst thing that
happens to you today to you is that you
think your child was snubbed by a fake
green monster then life's not too bad
life's great
well that's why they're so angry because
it is the worst things ever happened
yeah that's true peach is going to be
nuts you know there's going to be like
humans are going to be big balls of fat
and jelly sitting in hover chairs
they're going to have you know food
tubes or they can snap their fingers and
have literally anything they're going to
be literally gargling ice cream with
like vitamins in it and then one day
there's going to be a small burp in the
like just
the tube burps and they'll start
screaming and freaking out because the
burp was the worst thing they ever
experienced i i have to say when they
were talking about dystopias i had no
idea that our dystopia was going to be
like wall-e that is the closest thing to
the way it's actually going to be that
i've ever seen we need something like
wally to bumble through our freaking
wheelchairs and throw us all over but
the people in wall-e were chill
yeah they were just floating around like
whatever that was way off yeah soft
people floating around chairs would be
super angry about just the
stupidest nonsense ever they'd be like
they'd get their slushie or whatever
from the robot and they'd look at it and
it would be like a millimeter less than
they wanted to go
then they'd start crying and say they
were attacked and it's violence i was
murdered i was murdered that's right
except all the food is really made from
bugs yeah and it's just got flavorings
it's got monsanto flavorings to taste
like steak or to taste like chicken or
beef well that's what it's all just made
of insects that's where we're headed it
is
so why don't you eat the bugs daniel you
have a farm right yeah
i know certain you know cultures do eat
them i i don't you know i don't want to
eat bugs i'm not saying why not are you
racist
i'm like that green monster yeah um
do you know that eight percent of the
world eats bugs
yeah like i said a lot of clothes that's
true who eat bugs is that is that a real
they're not eating bugs because they
want to it's because they're poor
yeah like yeah wealthy people don't eat
bugs eat coffee
oh they do celebrities are like i'll try
to try a chocolate covered cricket whoa
is that what you eat yeah they do it's
it's something novel but no but i think
when it comes to food and what you're
doing and highlighting with the dutch
farmers and what i do in the energy
space
you know it's it's very much related and
and food insecurity is a growing problem
and holy crap we haven't even started to
eat this year's food because we're still
growing it so we don't even know what
prices are going to cost you know i get
asked about gas prices but we haven't
harvested this year's wheat yet and and
if there's any to harvest exactly if
there's any fuel to harvest what little
we do have i know that's going to be fun
huh so so the real food prices are are
bad now but the real kick is not going
to come until
october november wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait until the fertilizer
shortages kick in yeah well they already
did
they already i think earlier i think it
will be
a continual crisis next year it's going
to be your harvest because yeah russia's
not going to stop like the russian
ukraine stuff not it's not going to stop
but you know i got to say i'm very
frustrated with you guys look no one
cares about food and gas
they care about racist muppets and
abortion and abortion that's yeah racist
muppets getting abortions
can racist muppet men's get abortions
racist racist male muppets get abortions
elmo gets an abortion oh my gosh
sure why not
what is elmo what does it matter almost
a dude right i think elmo is almost a
boy
what
elmo is a boy's name isn't it saint elmo
you're almost fired but men can give
birth now that's true that's true it's
so closed-minded of course it's like
tickle me elmo abort me elmo the new i
was gonna say it i didn't do it
how far out do you think we are from
children's dolls that can be we can get
abortions um two months
that's a tough barbie didn't they do
didn't they use like a doll that
menstruates or something pregnant male
barbie i believe pregnant male barber
believe not sure you guys can fact
protect me on that pregnant male barbie
disturbing i wouldn't be surprised i
mean yeah frumpy barbie i mean it's all
part of grooming kids right they got to
yeah someone just banned groomer what
pla it wasn't it wasn't that story was
fake news oh it was oh yeah what
actually happened was that a single
subreddit said hey stop doing this
and that was it well
an article about that and then pink news
it's like
claimed that it was
groomer was calling all gay people peter
something like no just you i guess just
you yeah
yeah they said that it's a
groomer as an anti-lgbtq slur and i'm
like no no no it isn't i thought that
just the groomers what the heck but like
the joke i made the other day or the
point was there's like a creepy guy
looking at kids look at his lips and
then you're like you point to him and
you're like hey you you groomer you get
out of here and then he walks over next
to the group of gay guys and goes hey
he's making fun of us
and it's like no i'm not making fun of
them i'm telling you to get out of here
those guys are all right they're true
they're minding their own business i
don't care yeah
yeah uh pregnant ken is satire just for
the record i would put it at like six
months out i definitely see that
happening it does sound like a babylon b
yeah it does toy but the whole world
sounds like a babylon beer at this point
to be fair but you raised a great point
though like about about what we were
talking about energy issues food issues
but we do love to get distracted by
uh what's the benef benefit got married
that was i woke up the other morning and
usually one of the first things i do
which is a terrible habit you look at
what happened while i was asleep pulled
up my phone
start
first five stories we're all about ben
affleck and jennifer lopez getting
married and you're like really something
else must have happened last night
awesome here's the reality edward
snowden says we are all going to eat
crickets
people are like i'm not going to eat the
crickets oh you're going to eat the
crickets brother they're going to be
everywhere they're going to put them in
hot pockets your kids are going to be
like mom mom i want the pizza crickets
he's not wrong i saw this conspiracy
theory
if you can call it that i don't know
they said
in order to get people to eat crickets
you got to make them hungry first
because if people are hungry they will
eat anything
so now we're looking at these food
shortages we're looking at what's going
on the dutch farmers
dutch farmer is being told not to farm
at the same time the titans of food
charge is coming how dumb does that make
sense
it doesn't so we are going to all starve
maybe not us here and many at home might
not if they bought their emergency food
oh that's right but y'all are gonna be
eating crickets you know why he's right
about the hot pockets there's already a
company in canada have you seen this the
president's choice why they put crickets
in it they sell bags of crickets no no
i'm talking about there's a there's a a
chip company that puts cricket into
their snacks
so that you're like protein inching your
way there and an extra crunch
so imagine you get like they're like
cheeto puffs
and you eat a cheeto puff and it's made
of corn and cheese and so i feel like
this is good so they mix in maybe like
five percent cricket added protein and
then you're like this is good you do
that for a year or two and you keep
increasing the level of cricket in the
food and then eventually you do that
with cattle and like barley and molasses
you just increase the ration until
they're able to eat it they're going to
call it something else
they're not going to call it cricket
they're going to call it like s coke
like escargot
no it's good
it's going to be called like
arachne protein or something you know
like
and you're eating spiders or whatever
it's kitten so there's going to be a
whole yeah yeah yeah there's gonna be a
little marketing campaign about how you
eat lobsters so why would you not this
is just the crickets i don't think look
people ate high fructose corn syrup and
never knew what it was no one came to
them one day and said we're putting this
in your food they just started eating
and they're like at home so chitin there
you go yeah you're gonna you're gonna be
ordering a burger and they're gonna be
it's gonna be like 87 pure beef with
extra chitin and you're gonna go i don't
know and you're eating cricket well we
eat carrageenan which is an ice cream
that's actually from seaweed and it
gives ice cream like its shape it helps
keep its shape after it melts a little
bit which is really interesting if you
don't know that about the fact that
seaweed is an ice cream kind of gross
not really i don't know there you go
gorillas they're going to call it
grillous there you go yeah depending on
what they use cricket juvenile gorillas
campestris
and it's going to be like the
ingredients of your your chips it's
going to be like whole corn
cheese enzymes grillous protein and
you're gonna be like oh okay and you're
not gonna think twice about eating the
crickets big banner on the side now with
five percent more gorillas that's right
oh boy i mean gorilla sounds pretty good
right gorilla grilled food yeah yeah if
you like have you tried grilled grillis
you're going to be like what's grill
it's like a grill thing it's like a
thing they do in the grills man like
what i ordered cheeseburgers and it was
90 beef 10 grillis what's that oh it's
like it's for grilling
and they'll do commercials where they're
like grilled burger we i got a
commercial for kelp burger
not good gross yeah not good yeah uh i
like you know like mushroom and black
beans mixes with like you know
vegetables and stuff that's pretty good
seaweed but they try and do all sorts of
stuff but ladies and gentlemen y'all
going to be in the crickets whether you
want to or not you will not be able to
hide
yeah and until canada president's choice
is selling a pc cricket protein bar
grillions they call it brilliance we
were right i was right oh my god no way
that's amazing
slightly alternative that's great that's
insane
and this is on their website i thought
this maybe it was grillons yeah grillons
cricket grillons it's grillons yeah
g-r-i-c cricket protein bar
yeah chocolate mmm yummy who wants to
try cc cricket
from nutritionix
cricket grillings powder i was close
because the cricket was grillous camp
certainly it's only 19. 90 calories yeah
cricket that's the taste you already
find in the advantages not only does it
taste great it's healthy for you no it
doesn't taste good it doesn't taste
great
so we we ordered cricket powder
and then ian made a bread with it
and it's it's really astringent
is the way they describe the flavor
it's like it's sour and bitter bitter
yeah yeah it's sour if you season it i
think it'll be fine but i put some salt
yeah but maybe some vinegar diluted it
you did like half cricket half flour
it was it was too much cricket powder
too much cricket yeah if i had done more
wheat flour with water too much okay
great so
i'm okay with cricket i'm not i'm not
too worried you know people eat like you
said lobsters they like they eat
you know birds they eat
what's happening
first guy to ever eat a uh an oyster you
knew was crazy right someone looked at
that thing and opened it they were like
eat it like i'm not eating but i love
them i don't know
early humans ate random stuff anyway
that's yeah they were like well i'm
dying i'll eat this rock
that's better than nothing eat this bark
you know i like the joke it's like um
every time you eat mushrooms you need to
give thanks to every human who tried
mushrooms so you knew which one was safe
to eat yeah yeah because they died yeah
they're like i'll try it
but i mean up until
you know the the the industrial
revolution dutch farmers and and power
the future
the majority of the world was hungry all
the time i mean hunger drove
drove war it drove economies i mean
kings were hungry everyone was hungry
yes yes people lived in hunger a lot of
the wars were fought over just making
food taste better yeah true
absolutely they were like that ship's
carrying peppercorn fire yeah
yeah seize the peppercorn and then bring
it to the king and he'd be like oh and
now we just have it on like every diner
table oh exactly and but for you know
the the miracles of of the fossil fuel
industry and modern technology and and
we can argue at the 30 000 foot level
should we
use fossil fuels in the cultivation of
our agriculture
i'll have that conversation should we is
but we do
and yet these people as i'm not have to
explain to you you know better than i do
but the world economic forum and the the
klaus schwabs and the the john kerry's
are like we shouldn't and holland's
going to lead the way or sri lanka is
going to lead the way in all these
countries and now as all of a sudden
it's like wait a second but but we do
use although sri lanka more than than
the netherlands the netherlands is more
of a land seizure right but but sri
lanka well we're not going to use these
anymore well now we're in famine and and
we the john carries the klaus schwabs
from
thousand fifteen thousand miles away
look at it and say boy this is terrible
what's happening over there but if
you're a sri lankan and you're in true
famine yeah
how did your experiment go because
schwab is not gonna stop eating steaks
no he's not going gonna be the one who's
putting crickets on his hamburgers well
how old is that guy anyway ancient yeah
he's probably like i only have like
three years left anyway so i will eat
filet mignon until then
i can't believe i was told someone said
they liked porterhouse better than
tenderloin i'm like that doesn't make
sense to you but it's true people do i
like i look at a menu and i'm like well
i have any other option because some
people just like t-bones or i like new
york strip strip stick i mean it's good
but
maybe it's a cost thing maybe i want to
spend the money on tenderloin
i don't know that's kind of why don't
they why don't they just feed the cow
crickets there you go that's cow by the
way why don't we feed ourselves like i
eat pork well you eat pig just say it
call it pig cow i'm eating pig tonight
crickets man i have no personal issue
with eating bugs i have an issue with
people being forced to eat bugs or
tricked into eating bugs
or anything while they still eat steak
yes it's going to be like v for vendetta
yes when she's like is this real butter
oh i've never had this since that was a
child how did you get it he's like i
stole it from chancellor sutler's
personal supply cart or whatever
but it's not it's also not just like
them being tricked into eating
crickets it's them being forced to eat
crickets because that is the only food
that's been made available to them they
they lose out on the choice and over
time i think you're you're right about
them putting in pizza pockets it's like
beef is not going to be affordable to a
middle-class family much
less anyone below um and and then the
response is well we have these cheap
crickets here you can feed your kids you
can feed a family of six with these
so
you know whether is it them knowing it
or not
just the fact why crickets though aren't
there better tasting bugs i'm sure
roly-polies taste better than crickets
are you gonna kill bugs for those who
don't live in chicago or i don't know
you guys call them rolly pollies i have
no idea what that road yeah potato bugs
no no no potato bugs are different
pill bug maybe crickets don't have
anything in them that is inherently
dangerous
certain bugs slugs are deadly don't need
to ever eat a slug oh yeah i heard a
story about the guy who ate off the
ground as a dare and then
yeah so there are certain bugs you can't
eat but maybe crickets are are totally
clean escargot is pretty good i don't
know one of the one of the projects for
timcast.com as you guys expand is you
need to have
like a fun
press accountability uh component where
you go up to reporters who wrote glowing
stories about the future who were proven
categorically wrong and ask where they
are like the people who wrote about sri
lanka 2025 will be the the cleanest
country or the the richest country in
the world per capita or you know the
paul krugman's who are like the
internet's gonna be gone by the year
2000 or just i mean the the press when
it comes to climate issues food issues
socialism issues
they always write these glowing reports
about how great things are going to be
in three years everything falls to pot
and then they're like ho home news story
yeah well i think it was tucker that was
bringing up that like um
uh myanmar i believe it is sri lanka i'm
sorry true they're the ones who had the
best esg scores in the world followed by
like south africa i'm like these places
are not doing well so i don't know what
a high esg score looks like but it is
not good for the people
to find the story from the guy i know i
texted it to myself because it was so
great but this was the guy who wrote the
story about how
sri lanka is going to be the greatest
country in the world in a couple of
years and oh here it is jason hickle hey
jason's hope you're listening jason's
got 200 000 plus followers on social
media he's a professor uh he's got lots
of things in his professor of iketa uab
blah blah but he wrote the story about
yeah sri lanka was going to be the
greatest stagger a whole thread about
how great sri lanka is going to be when
they adopted all the csg stuff and you
want to go find jason hickle and say
jason where are you now because you know
what there's a sri lankan dad who's
feeding his kid crickets because they're
friggin starving to death they're
probably looking are you are you it's
not even are you good
how are things for the jason hickle
house
no compunction no sense of boy real we
really like like like took a turd in the
bed with this one they just move on you
know what though man it's all the big
cities and uh
after these past several years of
telling people to get away from cities
at a certain point it's just like i
don't know what else to do for you yeah
look
you can't grow food you can't grow
enough food to feed your family in the
city
you move out of the cities move to the
middle of nowhere you learn how to take
care of yourself and you can start
creating your own food so for instance
like for breakfast i eat eggs straight
from my own chickens but
granted we give the chickens feed but we
also there's also the bug technique
where you put the wood on the ground and
then every morning you lift the wet up
and move it and the chickens run over
and eat all the bugs you let the
chickens graze in the grass and eat the
bugs all day and the berries and then
they poop out the eggs for you then in
the winter you slowly run out of
chickens as you eat the chickens but we
got a ton we got like 30 or something
out there now it's crazy and then we
have we started cocktown i don't know if
we told you we got too many roosters
well it means rooster i know what you
guys are laughing at yeah
not a lot no no it's not not a laughing
we got too many roosters and uh the
roosters can't live together with girls
yeah so we move just don't call it
cocktown.com because well you can that's
a good one
it may be taken all right it may already
be taken
don't google it right
now
we had wild black raspberry and it's
such a weak plant it got strangled out
by the surrounding plants and it was
like it's a bummer
the wine raspberries take over
everything and they're everywhere and
they're delicious but uh
it's crazy living moving out of the city
and now it's like
maybe five percent or even actually not
even i think maybe around like 20 or 30
percent of the food i eat probably comes
from
my like my own source like it's it's the
chickens i eat i eat their eggs for the
most part it's like breakfast it's their
eggs
and then i have dinner so it's
i say like 20 because
it's just the eggs and then i'll have
dinner later and the dinner is more
substantial for the most part that's a
decent amount when we were gardening it
was much less but i would do like eggs
and like peppers and stuff
when
look when it hits the fan we got look at
this story it's from cbc from 2019
cricket beer
ladies and gentlemen right when it hits
the fan
you are going to be eating christmas
and we're going to have fresh eggs
because we moved out and we got more
space we got away from those cities but
the cost of living in a city is nuts
it's 5 000 per month on average for an
apartment in new york city for that cost
you can buy yourself a mansion
five grand or a hundred acre farm or a
hundred acre farm that's right and then
that's where i am and then you can just
slowly start figuring out like use the
luxury of the modern era to figure out
how to survive on your own before it's
too late man
yeah you know because we got
amazing tools and electricity
and so we're the chickens we don't need
to have chickens we like having chickens
the chickens are funny we film the
chickens people watch chickens and then
we eat the chicken's butt bounty those
eggs every day yeah we got so many
that's crazy but bounty that's what it's
called the bounty the chicken's butt
brought up the sri lanka stuff and also
the holland stuff like what happened
exactly to bring this famine on is there
is it would you consider famine at this
point in holland yeah uh no no not in
holland there's i mean there's
there's massive shortages in grocery
stores um so
that's i but that's not the definition
of a famine um what's going on in the
netherlands right now is the
prime minister and the court system
there are pushing this policy of
reducing nitrogen emissions by 2030. so
by 2030 the nitrogen emissions have to
be down by 30 40 percent and to do that
that means farmers are going to have to
cull their herds
because
there's a lot of nitrogen emissions
throughout the whole process of raising
cattle pork and and all this so by
culling by culling the herds they lose
their profit margins farm farms aren't
the most profitable ventures you can go
into most people are in it because their
families were in it for a long time so
they they do this job and they say okay
call 30 of the herd they no longer can
afford to keep that land and for some
reason keep in mind the dutch government
has said this is only going to be in
effect in environmentally sensitive
areas which which just happens to be
around big cities and coastlines
high-value real estate which has caused
people to say well why are you targeting
us why why do you want the land is that
what you really want and it's become
clear that that's what the dutch
government wants they want to evict
these farmers they don't care about the
food they want the land and these are
farms that have been in families since
the 13th century like this is europe
we're talking about right it's not not
even america uh where the farm that
we're on right now or the farmland that
we're on
has been
uh you know farmed by americans for 200
300 years back there it's been
to you know 10 centuries so
it's pretty tragic what's happening
there and it's even more tragic that the
mainstream media isn't giving them a
fair shot at saying their piece they're
immediately taking the government's side
and saying
you know they're extremists just like
the people that went to ottawa they're
you know they're racists they're
they have no idea what they're talking
about but
in reality they do know what they're
talking about and if you're not trusting
the farmers with our food supply i don't
know i don't think you should be
trusting journalists so this is a
kingdom it's the kingdom of the
netherlands yes this is king is is
orchestrating this ah no uh it's it's a
it's
it's run
by a parliament by a government by a
parliament
so we've got a free shortage we've got a
fertilizer shortage we've got fuel
shortages
they don't know if they'll be able to to
have enough fuel to harvest what they
did grow let alone
you know if they could grow anything at
all because of the fertilizer shortage
they're telling us that the surrounding
countries outside of europe are going to
be in serious crisis because of the lack
of food because they won't get imports
from russia and ukraine and when
so lebanon may start turning into sri
lanka and then they tell the dutch
farmers stop farming
if the food's already stopped production
why do they need to stop cut down the
nitrogen you know these countries are
eating themselves alive it's
self-immolation it is self-immolation
and it's just like joe biden cancels
keystone xl and then and then gas prices
go through the roof it's like why did
you do that you knew what was going to
happen i mean you didn't know maybe you
didn't know russia was going to go to
war in the ukraine but you knew what
would happen with with uh keystone xl
and now uh
leaders around the world from sri lanka
to the netherlands and canada justin
trudeau is doing the exact same thing
putting limits on fertilizer use in our
country by by 30 he wants to reduce
fertilizer use and what does that mean
well half the planet is fed by
fertilizer in one way or another 50 of
the planets mouths
ingest food because of
fertilizer which is frankly a gift from
god
um from russia we yeah well from russia
from from lots of places and and now
they're saying well justin trudeau is
saying specifically let's reduce that by
30 to help the environment well that's
reducing food output by a substantial
margin you don't just
there's no technology that replaces
fertilizer you don't just plant crops
more straight or give it more water
without the fertilizer it doesn't grow
and you don't feed people and then the
question is who's not eating who's not
well i'm eating i bought emergency food
i got anything to worry about and the
funny thing is is that like suddenly
it's nitrogen that's what i would like
yeah like where did we decide nitrogen
was this thing that had to be regulated
because we've always heard about methane
but methane is when it comes to the
fossil fuel industry so it's like oh we
can't have oil and gas because that's
methane but when it comes to farming
it's nitrogen it's like oh how come it's
not methane because they don't have any
oil in in holland but they do have farms
so nitrogen is what we have to control
and you're like well that's odd where
was the
the decision that nitrogen is suddenly
this just like co2 carbon remember joe
biden said at the the scotland climate
summit that he was going to work with
the leaders around the world to rid the
atmosphere of carbon that would destroy
the planet exactly and all the planets
of the world were like please no like
like everything alive but we've decided
carbon is bad and you want to say
where does this come from like what is
the driving impetus of this oh it's not
about nitrogen or methane or carbon it's
about land it's about power it's about
oh
now it makes a lot more sense soon
they're going to be regulating oxygen
exactly that's the next one yeah it's
just that this is just an enormous power
grab it's a land grab and europe is
going to have land grabs because europe
is small no offense to our european
friends we love you but europe is
continental europe is smaller than
america
obviously then a lot much smaller than
canada there isn't a lot of land there
to begin with um so the land is going to
be their biggest problem
it's power did you guys see the viral
video of the man
in his bin full of water in the uk no
it's hilarious video why is he in water
because it's the hottest day in history
in the uk so he took his garbage bin and
he filled it with water and he was
sitting in it good for him
some guy pulls in that car and he's like
you're in the bin and he's like yeah and
he's like why and he's like i'm enjoying
the day and he's like but you're in the
bin
and then the guy like i'm pretty sure
it's fake but it's hilarious anyway it's
funny but it's like the the uk doesn't
have air conditioning i don't know if
you guys know this europe doesn't
yeah it was crazy i went to the i went
to the uk for a speaking event they put
me in a hotel on the top floor it was
like third or fourth floor and it was
like 90 some odd degrees
and then i was like guys like i have to
i have to go
to a speaking event
and i'm drenched in sweat because it's
so hot up here what am i supposed to do
and so they're like we'll try and figure
out a box fan for you i'm like that's
not gonna do anything but it's like
people are crazy but at least they're
green by stuffing everyone who's super
sweaty into public transit so they stand
shoulder to shoulder with people who
smell like socks i have an article from
seven years ago you're up to america
your love of air conditioning is stupid
i really have to say i wonder if they
still think that now yeah which
journalists wrote that let's name it no
they're going to say that our use of air
conditioning created more carbon
emissions which made the planet hotter i
agree yeah for sure we just need to
plant more trees man yeah you know trees
they eat carbon there's just any others
have to ignore all of these fake metrics
because it's a it's a much more a
nefarious agenda that has nothing to do
with the environment or the planet you
know i
i think climate change is an issue i
think pollution is an issue whether
whether you believe in climate change or
not i think human pollution is awful but
it's really just the cities
and so you know we've talked about this
with people like michael malus and our
where we come to agreement is cities are
too dense and the cities produce a ton
of waste like if you had
one guy let's save 100 people
and they're spread out
over
a mile each person and they all take a
dump
right all at once right when you drive
100 miles you might notice every mile
there's some poop on the ground or you
might just be like oh i didn't even
realize imagine if those 100 people all
got together in the same city block
formed the circle and took a big dump
you would definitely notice that and the
density of the human waste would cause
ecological problems this is what's
happening with these big cities they're
gluttonous
immature whiny resource hogs
it's extremely resource intensive to get
food into new york city the roads are
congested there's brake dust and smog
and pollution but you got to get that
food in there so now people are spending
five grand per month on average to get
an apartment the cost of living is
through the roof and then you move out
of the city and it's like really easy to
get to the grocery store
way less wasteful
there's the thing about people who live
in the countryside right
more likely to have so their own source
of food even if it's a little bit
people out here they got chickens you
know i i'll see houses they'll have like
two or three chickens and i'm like
they're getting some of their food on
their own the chickens will go and eat
bugs or grass and then they'll get eggs
from it that's a little bit of making
their own food they're more likely to be
to have solar power it's harder to get
solar if you're in an apartment in new
york city so you have the houses out in
the middle of nowhere and people have
more renewable energy sources
i just look at the people who are living
out here and it's like
well water yes so family at a well yeah
so they're not creating these big sewage
wastes the the septic systems handling
the waste and then putting the the leach
water out but yeah which are the people
who are pushing the climate agenda
though the people who want to fly around
in private jets the people who most of
them live in the city
right they're the ones like you said
they are huge energy sucks and they tell
you you live on the 87th floor of a
building and you don't think that
requires tremendous fossil fuel did you
see who was it kylie or whoever she flew
oh yeah private jet she flew on a
private jet for 12 minutes and it was
funny because they said that she drove a
half an hour in the wrong direction to
to get to the airport for a trip that
would have taken 20 mile 26 minutes to
drive
oh my god so like it took her longer to
drive to the airport to get on the plane
to fi to fly like 20 miles or whatever
that's a very short two airports very
close to each other
oh yeah wasn't it elon musk who jumped
from like san francisco to like san jose
over the bay it was like a ten minute
flight
that's incredible it's hey it's an hour
two hour drive with traffic that flight
was five minutes that's great and if
you're elon you're like hey time is
money baby let's roll yeah that's that's
that's a good thing yeah and i don't
begrudge them
that privilege i don't begrudge them i
don't believe fossil fuels are bad so
i'm never gonna say well we all have to
do our part to conserve i just don't i
don't buy that argument what i do
begrudge are people who do that who want
to deny the rest of us that opportunity
like the john kerry's of the world who
right now is in some german resort and
the alps planning the climate conference
and he flew there on his private jet and
he's like but we have to get rid of our
fossil fuels it's like well you you're
never going to not eat steak right
you'll do the same with you i'm sure
klaus is at that meeting right and and i
would love to know what the the caviar
selection that was there yeah somebody
said tim didn't grow that vita coco
it came out of a chicken's butt yeah it
did
actually hawaiian chicken we actually
have a big coconut palm tree and peaches
and mangoes and it's all all hot enough
here i didn't say all of our food was
was grown by us
it was great having the garden your
water is oh yeah filtered pure well
water yeah it's amazing
that's good oh yeah yeah yeah but it's
like super purified and then minerals
added back into it great
yeah and then for free damastan with the
new studio it's basically off the grid
are you gonna pump fluoride into the
water systems oh we do yeah we do double
the fluoride
yeah
the new space has got its own pond good
that we're going to clean up it's got
well water obviously there's a pond
right there
we've got solar power and backup
batteries so we're going to try and be
as self-sufficient as possible
uh it's not about like saving the planet
it's about just not getting getting
disrupted when we're doing work yeah but
you know hey i can then be smug and make
fun of all the city or urban the city
urban liberal types and be like wag my
finger at them based on their own
standards
no everyone should be as self-sufficient
as possible i'd love to have a small
nuclear reactor in my backyard yes
it would be fantastic and and we thought
about it because again when back to the
future came out at the end he's got his
little mr fusion right in the back of
the car we we thought that's what the
future was going to be a little tiny
nuclear reactor in the back of your car
we weren't afraid of it in
1984 whenever that came out but we're
afraid of it now all right we're gonna
go to super chats if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and share the
show if you do like it head over to
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only show coming up at 11 p.m uncensored
tim cast after hours but until then we
will read your super chats let's see we
got
james eaton says when will your album be
out and will there be an option to buy a
signed copy
man we didn't really plan uh any of that
stuff i'm think we were thinking like
august 21st or something the week of the
third week of august
and uh some of the songs are just really
really great we'll see i mean there's
like one song totally done there's one
song that's really close to being done
there's like five songs that are like
moderately done
we'll see man it'll be cool i also kind
of felt like doing albums is dumb
we're not in that era anymore maybe
we'll do a vinyl press or something but
like people are gonna go on spotify or
pandora to listen to it or something
like that or itunes or whatever
so we'll see man you know
all right let's see
chibineo says tim please examine h.r
1808 a highly restrictive bill to limit
firearms ownership in an extreme way
before the judiciary tomorrow look it up
i will look into it
travis jackson says how long until we
get the chicken city animated chickens
to do the bio trust spot yes i don't
know let's do it
all right
raymond g maga stanley junior iii says
aoc's big smug smile is pure lunatic
narcissism
yup juicy smiley yeah that was crazy
it's just so creepy to see her faking
being handcuffed yeah and ellen ombar
did the same thing it's all for
photographs yeah
yeah the cops should have been like to
put your hands down like put your hands
to your side
he should have actually cuffed her but
on the front yeah put your hands on the
front we're gonna cuff you and then just
not do it yeah
all right
justin justice forrest says hey tim wait
until a poor man in texas forces a woman
who makes more money than him to have
his baby and then she has to pay him for
alimony and child support the left will
scream about unfairness and will never
see the irony hey that's
that's crazy too
and we're getting there
shifted paradigm zach orton says tim you
should try to get mark dice on your show
he's very knowledgeable about government
and things that are purposefully hidden
from society i'm pretty sure we've
reached out to him several times he's
great but he's very one of those very
busy people yeah he's a busy fellow
that's busy dude huh love to yeah be
great mark nice says this reminds me of
the zone of death in yellowstone where
murder could theoretically happen and
you wouldn't get prosecuted for it
because there is no residence in that
district to fill a jury
really is that true i'm sure that sounds
like an urban legend theoretically yeah
well
i don't know the feds would come in and
have you try you in a federal
jurisdiction or something
not enough people to fill a jury
tetra says hey tim and crew wife has a
rare dental condition that needs surgery
would appreciate all the help we can get
gofundme
slash rare dental condition needs
treatment and surgery well good luck
it's long but yeah good luck yeah man
raymond g magazine junior iii says
bleeding colorado may be the new
bleeding kansas look i'm not saying any
of that stuff is happening but i'm just
like what happens if that scenario does
arise i mean that would be
it's an untenable situation like the
texas government says sorry man your
kid's being taken to be killed ain't
nothing we can do about it
it's gonna get crazy but we can't we
can't prevent good laws from being
enacted out of fear of how that law will
be uh interpreted or or used in the
future you can't build a you can't say
don't build a beautiful church because
someone may burn it down
right so you have to pass laws that are
just and right
understanding that in the future it's
going to be
muddy and dirty that's society but it's
still the right decision sorry super
chats no no it's uh it's like you know
people who say that they're scared of
getting a dog because they know the dog
is going to die it's going to be sad and
it's like
so you give up all of the like a decade
of love
like when you're sad your dog dies
it's not a it's not a bad thing it's
like all of that
all of that
gift of joy given to you by the dog
being released all at once
you got to pay your dues man sad enough
to the dog how many people do it with
with
a human being all right you know i can't
possibly date someone or fall in love or
get married because the person may hurt
me one day wow that's a great way to
live your life it's terrible oh tragic
yeah
all right
onward abu baker says i tried finding
the statute relating to abortion that
indicates you can abort until birth the
state of colorado can't find it so i
looked it up it's the the new uh
abortion bill they passed and it's just
there's no restrictions in it that's
that's the issue is that the bill they
passed just does not have any
restrictions so
i was reading some website about it too
and it was talking about how there's
nothing codified preventing these things
tattered shields has sent a super chat a
while ago about goblin tokens and made a
video on it it's a post called tim
learns about goblins also anyone who
voted for biden has no right to
criticize the way trump spoke
that's a fair point you can criticize
trump like he had a potty mouth and it's
like yeah and joe biden's got a demented
mouth i don't know
there's equal issues there i suppose
josh as i award ian no points and may
god have mercy on his soul that's a good
quote though
kamlov says ian is saying just because
you think something it doesn't mean it's
real is exactly what's wrong with this
country
augusto says ian is right murder is
defined by the state there is no federal
government law against murder
is that true i don't know that sounds
crazy no that sounds right though oh
interesting
yeah i don't know someone look it up
yeah normally when i think about it when
when they go to federal court it's
usually on like violation of civil
rights right they you know that's
interstate commerce stuff yeah but
they're but
that's that's a great again that's why
we need some good lawyers and and
you have good you have good tim cast
super fans who know these things
kaipak says stop bashing colorado we did
not vote for this
didn't colorado vote for this i don't
know
well that's what they're getting maybe
you should vote republican i guess
all right seeds of truth says what makes
me aggravated about ian is that he has
no courage to stand for
stand for or value anything nothing is
worth dying for or fighting for and no
idea is worth asserting for him a man
with no chest i'd love to see you make
some youtube videos and put your face
behind those words oh
maybe he does maybe he does yeah send me
a link to your youtube channel
make 1984 fiction again says ian saying
killing a baby is murder is
post-modernism you cannot agree on words
you are the poster child for
post-modernism right back at you i said
not that killing a baby is
post-modernism fellow but that calling
something murder when it's not because
you feel like it is is post-modernism
joseph mcfarland says tim the
jurisdiction issue you presented to ian
is precisely the type of event that
kicked off the hatfield mccoy war
and lawful courts were involved in all
actions prior to that kicking off
yeah i don't know a whole lot about that
i looked that up yeah
i just remember the bugs bunny episode
about it but i don't think that was
based totally in fact
patriot says ian just made the same
argument about abortion re-colorado v
texas that slave owners made for the
legality of the treatment of and
sometimes killing of their slaves it's
not murder because they don't have
rights
actually that's that's that's right
you saying it's not murder because the
state defines murder and they're not
defining it as murder is exactly why
slave owners were allowed to kill people
i'm making a legal argument right they
used legal arguments for that too
doesn't mean that legal arguments are
wrong and my argument stands as well
that eventually people stormed into
those states and started like john brown
shot multiple people in the face yeah
and my argument was dred scott was a
legal decision it was the wrong one but
that's what the law said and so
yeah so i think
uh to that point
yeah we are dangerously close to a
situation like a john brown bleeding
kansas kind of circumstance where some
dude just says they're literally
trafficking
women kidnapping the children of these
guys to kill them and they're going to
go up and someone's going to it's going
to be a fight over what if a woman a
pregnant woman drank alcohol in the baby
miscarried and then they murdered her
they killed they executed her for murder
that's crazy i don't think that's a good
let's not go there so this is actually
it's not an issue
where there are mothers who are getting
very long prison terms and they're
saying it's all but it's because they
miscarried and you read it and it's
because these women knew they were
pregnant and did things like meth
voluntarily they just continued with
their drug use and their baby died and
they're like that's actually a crime you
should be more careful about this little
person who's dependent on you not
alcohol as such but hard drugs so
alcohol is a hard drug guy all good says
federal law specifies what happens over
borders by the constitution the legal
term you're looking for is called
sovereignty and each state holds dual
sovereignty with the federal government
there was a period like 10 years ago or
longer where a bunch of states started
like asserting sovereignty like being
like we want to make sure everybody
knows this
interesting yeah look that up
all right carpe donctum is that the
carpe doctor what says if you can figure
out how to drive across state lines to
buy weed you can do it to kill your baby
true man that's crazy
all right
we'll grab some zuba juice eric miller
says texas abortion is illegal colorado
abortion is legal the fed's abortion is
on our the feds abortion is on our radar
well the biden's defended it so i mean
let's
let's look at this way
what happens if okay so i gave you a
scenario right now i got a crazier one
what happens if a woman in texas gets
pregnant
and uh and then she's fighting with the
guy eight months on and she's like you
know what i'm getting rid of this baby
baby i can't live with this guy and she
goes to colorado the guy calls the local
police and says help help she's
kidnapped my unborn son and plans to
abort him she then posts on social media
like ha ha you'll never stop me i'm
gonna do it i'm in colorado and i'm
allowed to
and then president trump goes excuse me
we're sending in law enforcement and
feds to stop this what if the feds
actually do intervene on behalf of texas
for a violation of the law and then do
go and arrest her
what's colorado going to do you'd think
that they should be like the law of the
place where your permanent address is
should be what applies to you
that's that's i mean that's what i don't
know i think what happened in canada i
just i don't think like
what if the federal government said
we're going to go in and
arrest this woman to bring her back to
stop her from killing this kid is
colorado going to be like okay or are
they going to be like you can't come
here and take someone who listens yeah
they can't the federal government's not
involved the federal government threw
their hands up in the air with
overturning roe v wade they're not i'm
saying what would happen if donald trump
gets elected and then says we will
protect the child and sends in federal
law enforcement to arrest the woman for
kidnapping then you arrest the federal
law enforcement with local police and
welcome to civil war yeah
no man when the or you just don't comply
like you lie to them you move them
around like they would do when the feds
would go try and bust dispensaries for
weed in california
atf agent get arrested he was trying to
serve a warrant and he wouldn't comply
with the police so they arrested him not
really the same thing that was more of
just like a if a cop tells you to put
your hands up don't go but i'm a cop
shut up i gotta think the states would
win because look at uh sanctuary city
laws
on the state level when the state says
we're not going to tell the feds that we
have illegal immigrants in our state
yeah and the feds are like you're
hosting illegal immigrants and the state
says we're not going to say anything the
feds never come in and guns are blazing
saying we're going to get them anyway
the fed's back down i got to think the
same precedent would happen that
although the feds have jurisdiction the
states have
seniority
as my hunch because it's a state law
this is interesting again not a lawyer
dance alloy says ian what about
california murder statute on the books
if someone kills a fetus it's murder how
do you rationalize that 30 odd states
have the same law so i think in
california if like you punch a woman in
the face and she falls down and the baby
dies you get murder for the baby too
if you kill someone else's baby that's
illegal illegal killing but if the woman
wants to kill her own baby in an
abortion that's not illegal so it's not
murder
so like this is this is where there's a
there's a fracture of the moral logic if
the woman
uh takes an illegal drug and kills the
baby does she get charged west lydia
pointed out that's been happening
so it's like
if the woman kills the baby
through a mean other than at an abortion
clinic it is murder
but if she asks the doctor to do it it's
not murder
the same outcome i don't think i don't i
don't know what california law it would
be a statute i guess the question is
would using a coat hanger count as a
murder then
i don't know i don't know what the law
is crazy stuff man no easy answer to any
of this stuff
but the point is killing the baby in the
woman is murder in like 30 odd states
that he says
if i killed her baby without her
permission yes it would be murder
probably everywhere but like imagine
having a seven-year-old kid and being
like i'm allowed to kill it it's my kid
yep like that's the moral failing
there's a logical fracture that makes no
sense you can't just be like a woman can
decide to kill her kid unless it's
escaped the two inches of her gullet
birth canal yeah
she can like so here's the thing a woman
can cut herself open take the baby out
and then kill it
like oh how about this a woman gives
birth on prom night and throws the baby
in a dumpster
she goes prison yeah because it's born
that makes no sense it's not illogical
so it's like it's just the way it's
written this is the point i made on
twitter that triggered the left i was
like what if a woman is like
speeding to the abortion clinic
and then she gets inside and she goes
quick quick i need an abortion before
it's born oh no and then she gives birth
right on the floor of the abortion
clinic it's like ah too late well ralph
northam was like you know we'll have a
conversation we'll keep the baby
comfortable and have that conversation
that's why my dad was always pro-choice
up until 18 years of age because he was
like you all should have been aboard
sometime in high school he's like we
should always have that i mean dad's
militantly pro-life he's catholic but
that was his joke who's like if you're
gonna allow abortion you need to give me
at least like another 16 17 years after
birth
yeah like what about what about what
northam said yeah
like
now you can literally kill the baby
after birth when he said the baby would
be delivered made comfortable baby's
made comfortable i'll be your mother and
the doctor have a conversation about
what to do next yeah
about whether or not to execute the
living child oh what do you mean it's
not legally wrong so it's not execution
it's abortion right
uh no no the baby's already born it's
not an abortion legally he's saying it
would be
right it would be like saying like a
post-death killing if they're dead you
can't kill them if they're born you
can't abort them if the state says you
can abort a baby outside the womb ian
that's your argument that's not an
abortion that's a kill
so i mean a kill abortion could be
considered a kill but it's a
non-abortion kill at that point no
you're wrong the state doesn't say that
the state defines murder well abortion
is the determination of a pregnancy if
the pregnancy's over and the baby's born
the final abortion's gone now no longer
if northam says is post-birth abortion
then it is it's not murder if he says it
then it must be real that's literally
what you argued that it's not murder
because the state has defined it as
murder i'm making your maybe it's not a
murder in that state i don't know
well virginia was proposing that it
didn't go through but that's what they
were proposing
which is so like i think it doesn't
matter what they can write down on paper
like if you kidnap someone and force
them to work for you you have commit you
are committing an atrocity against
humanity
what legality it does matter what's
written down because if you're gonna
want to go to war with someone and kill
their civilians or kill their military
age men uh you can't do it it's murder
but if you sign the paperwork now it's
legal
tritan 54 says tim the trial of the
murder of david doran started yesterday
just something i thought you might want
to keep an eye on ian you seem to get a
little emotional a few days ago i hope
you're doing okay
yeah i'm a little
distraught with the negativity of like
hating on people but um you know one day
at a time keep breathing
all right mr obvious says dropping 50
big ones youtube removed my 4chan hunter
about an iphone story it got 100k views
and was done in a mock documentary style
claimed it was harassment and cyber
bullying baloney i'm mad as hell and i'm
not going to take it anymore i'm
speaking out hey i appreciate it man
thanks for the super chat and uh oh good
luck i don't know
tina collett says colette my prediction
is that biden will sell our wheat
harvest causing a booze shortage there
will be violent riots but no molotov
cocktails
oh no
oh jeez
adrian curry says ian is a nice guy
thanks adrian ian is too nice of a guy
that says that's that's your biggest
problem is that when your heart is so
big you don't you don't know how to
control all of its borders
ian is too nice of a guy joe doraki says
i am super super charting this super
charting just so tim will say watch pop
cult culture crisis monday through
friday live 3 p.m eastern 12 pacific yes
ps ian kills it on pcc oh then you might
want to watch thursday
afternoon at 3 p.m pop culture crisis
we're doing a big time square thing
again and we're gonna have a big roberto
junior rooster up on times square
finally and i posted that people were
like that's so dumb it's a waste of
money and i'm like i know it's funny but
it's actually part of a big timcast.com
like ad thing we're doing so putting
roberto jr up there is going to actually
catch a lot of attention and be really
worth it because people are going to be
like why is there a giant rooster just
like what is this and then it's like a
bunch of other ads don't put the url to
cocktown.com
we don't own that one okay all right
maybe cocktail.org
excuse me
dot org is the right one though
dot org i really believe that org is
probably already taken
we're gonna get in trouble
[Laughter]
ozzy the terrible says tim need to have
movie watch night with soylent green
they live idiocracy and demolition man
and doctor strangelove the cult is
merging the stories together they were
telling us what they wanted to do
a.d
and v for vendetta two
it would be cool if we can get the like
the rights to do something like that
like um like live reaction to movies
like mystery science theater but
you know not just comic but
political shows and stuff i don't know
if we can do that for copyright reasons
though you should make if someone could
make bronzo though that would be great
yeah right yeah brown dough it's got
electrolytes
it's what plants crave
tommy uh groshong says a porterhouse is
a t-bone with new york strip stick on
one side and tenderloin filet on the
other side oh yeah it is delicious but
the filet mignon is just so bitter
medium rare
just melts in your mouth
a true free thinker says i would gladly
pay you tuesday for a bug burger today
what was that was that guy's name
wimpy wimpy
i would gladly pay you tues tuesday and
then tuesday comes around and he's like
well i'll pay you now but i still want a
burger so give me the money back
yeah okay
jacob perez says tim in mexico there's a
local aztec delicacy enjoyed in states
like oaxaca where grasshoppers are fried
marinated in lime juice salt and garlic
you know not for me people can be wrong
people that's true that's true sometimes
entire countries as well yeah that's
true too
is that like a weird thing that
americans eat that other countries think
is nasty
yeah like deep fried everything high
fructose oh everybody loves garlic a lot
of yeah
sodium
yeah splenda i think it's terrible oh
yeah the eu has long lists of stuff
that's not allowed in the eu but we eat
here yeah you're telling with that it
has like uranium in it yeah we were
looking at that right before the show
yeah there's a whole list of stuff
something like chocolate chip cookies
have like cadmium and uh um yam fries or
what was sweet potatoes yeah sweet
potatoes really weird right yeah you
think they're healthy they're not
healthy no so they can have like
unhealthy deposits of heavy metals yeah
right depending on where they're grown
i'm sure
all right
kevin brant says can i get a shout out
for my birthday the d is silent in my
last name also what happens when a
company pays a texas employee to get an
abortion
oh wow
that's interesting
like does it amazon's got employees in
texas right
yeah
yeah that's what they that's
facilitating criminal activities that's
what the four thousand dollars is for to
leave the state and
like i'm pretty sure if you're in texas
and you give someone money to commit a
crime somewhere else like there's still
a crime there i don't think so because
if if i was in a state where a drug was
illegal and i'm like i'm gonna go to
another state and do it they don't care
you're paying them to do it that's what
i'm saying so imagine being like i want
you to commit x here's money go do it
and do it across the state line
especially pretty sure it's still
illegal if the transaction happened in
this right like i i would assume it's
similar for america but in canada like
we charge canadians who go and fight for
isis you know they come they that crime
was over there but when they come back
still you still charge them with
terrorism or murder or whatever it is
this is going to get weird
yeah the way it's implemented sounds i
don't think texas is going to invade
colorado all i know is that if i was a
dude living in texas and i worked for
amazon in today's world culture every
week i would need my four thousand
dollars for another abortion i would go
to hr because i could how do you know
you're getting sued for this i would go
to hr like like every week you can't get
pregnant that often but how often can i
get pregnant yeah i can get pregnant
every day every two months i would go
and be like i need another four grand
abortion money well what's the link here
like abortion maybe they say one person
at a time so are you saying
is that what you're accusing me of these
companies are being i can't sleep around
these companies are being sued for
discrimination because they're offering
a benefit only to females that's true
and that's sexual discrimination so if
they're going to offer a medical benefit
in that degree it has to be equal to men
and women yeah so so i would get it all
the time yeah no you'd argue i think the
argument is simple it's like well my
girlfriend needs it oh perfect yep
give me the money
they might say that we don't pay for it
we we like we don't pay you we pay for
the trip and the expense and the bill
when you when you submit it okay cool
yeah i'll be in colorado for four days
yeah i'll i'll be the four seasons
denver
having my abortion
i mean here's an interesting question
then what happens if a doctor in
colorado forges invoices and just sends
them to the com to amazon texas yeah
and then it's like well the feds it's
illegal here so do something about it i
mean it's fraud i don't think there's
really a lot of forgery
or fraud in the medical profession
yeah you're probably right
i'm sure that's not a thing yeah
i don't think
invoicing fake medical procedures i
don't think that's a thing forging
prescriptions yeah you got to be honest
to experiment on people tim live live in
the now live in the reality stop making
up these hypotheticals
all right ian kinney says you should
check out the world economic forum's
first movers coalition headed by john
kerry they're going to be attacking a
lot of industries
yikes
calvin ramsey is not pro-choice but i
worry that women who now have have to
give birth will have disdain for the
child hope they embrace it could bring
them happiness
i believe that probably like 99 of women
who have the kids will not
feel regret or anger or disdain maybe
not 99
but uh
the only like it's really simple like
obviously if you have the kid you're
gonna be like i love my child i'm glad i
didn't do it and if you do abort it
you're like i don't know there's no kid
to love so it's funny when you see women
who get abortion say it was the greatest
choice of my life and then women who are
like i thought about getting an abortion
and changed my mind and it was the
greatest decision of my life it's like
well yeah because your life is what it
is now and you're content doing what
you're doing
like you will be happy with kids for the
most part some people aren't that's why
i say for the most part
the rectifier says tim thank you for
everything you do my brother recommended
your channel a few months ago i've since
felt the need to run for office to try
to make a difference here here glad
we'll go for it man best of luck
change the world
mama says taking a minor across state
lines is a federal crime and the feds
will prosecute abortions will likely
fall under the interstate commerce
clause
that's interesting
the the federal government might not say
it was for the abortion they might say
for an illicit service illegal in the
state in question
so i have to wonder
i have no idea how any of that will work
victor reznov says who says trump will
do anything about cross-state abortions
did he do anything to stop or address
the 2019 riots
what is giving you this you mean 2020
rights yeah i mean i guess they're right
in 2019 as well
yup
joshua renner says i've been to an
orphanage in quito in the 90s saw a
photo of a baby abandoned in a shopping
bag covered with fire ants dropped off
by cops the infant like that to the
orphanage wow
i don't know man i don't know man
this is getting absolutely crazy my
friends if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button
and uh subscribe to the channel head
over to timcast.com
we're going to have a an uncensored
after-hours show coming up at 11 p.m
tonight you don't want to miss it and
when you sign up you're signing up
through parallel economy which is uh dan
bongino's involved in it you said he was
a founder yeah one of them one two
founders
it's a censorship resistance payment
processor which means we are taking the
steps to challenge silicon valley's
stranglehold over
big tech we want to change it when you
sign up at timcast.com you're helping
them you're helping us you're helping
change that system
the goal with teamcast.com was we're
going to make more shows like members
only shows tv shows documentaries comedy
specials to start challenging disney and
netflix and hulu to put it this way
we're not going to make woke content and
instead of me telling you just cancel
your disney now and sign up for us you
could you should fine
i'd rather not have you stop watching
shows you like and just to the for the
three shows we have i want to make more
shows and prove we're going to have
excellent content that is worth your
money because that's how you really win
regular people over y'all may be
mission-driven and say i'm going to sign
up for timcast.com because i believe in
this but how do we get the regular
people who subscribe to netflix to stop
doing it we need to give them meaningful
alternatives so head over to timcast.com
and again smash that like button
would you kindly and uh you can follow
the show at tim cast irl you can follow
me personally at tim cast kian you want
to shout anything out yeah i would love
if everyone went to dutchuprising.com
that's where we're publishing all of our
content about
it's i mean it's grown from the
netherlands to uprisings around the
world but it really started with the
dutch and all of our coverage about
what's going on with the dutch farmers
there you can check it out and pitch
into our coverage as well we're all
viewer funded so it goes a long ways
right on daniel turner power of the
future powerthefuture.com daniel turner
ptf on platforms if you want to talk
about the radical green movement and the
importance of energy and the love of
fossil fuels or if you love farmers
bristol farm virginia on instagram
bristol farm virginia for your your
favorite sheep farmers and they're fun
and and cattle as well but it's a fun
little
goat's milk and stuff like that uh no
goats sheep sheep and cows uh you know
we decided not to milk the sheep because
it's just
one more thing to do so
in time you know we'll build out in time
we'll build up meat and wool for now
yeah but in time
sure oh okay great get some sheep and
buy a whole lamb
all right let's do that in
november in november and then we'll what
do we do put it over an open open pit
i can bring it to you uh you spin the
thing i can we can give it to you
butchered and vacuum sealed and you can
get all the different cuts or it can
give you the whole darn thing what if
you just came over to free diamond stand
with the whole darn thing and we just
like roasted it outside over a pyre or
something how could you do so some
massive fire that'd be sweet yeah
easy that would be like you know
brutal
very very game of thrones
cottage core yeah yeah primal yeah
primal that's the word yeah and then so
one big put an apple with that exactly
and then a little tiny one with little
tiny crickets a little little tiny spit
over here
like one crank that turns like 16 little
one little match you know it's just like
a rotisserie and we'll get another small
one with a broccoli for the vegans
exactly exactly so bristol farm virginia
it's a wonderful wonderful instagram and
great to be here with you all and like i
said i am serious your biggest problem
is you have a big heart when you have a
huge heart you have lots of borders and
you can't control your borders and all
the bad gets in but all the good gets
out and ian's biggest problem is that
his heart is very very big when you have
a small heart like me
you can control it very very well but
then there's not an awful lot of love to
give so you would much rather have a big
heart than a small one you might be
right i i sometimes i think about the
horror that i would inflict on my
enemies but that's uh i try not to have
enemies because i don't want to inflict
horror on humans so um let's hope that
we don't go to that place ever no and
keep things nice calm and peaceful see
you guys later i'm ian crossland ian
crossland.net bye for sure one of the
ways i stay positive is by following
bristol farms on instagram it is very
cute and sweet the evenings the summer
evenings with the little lambs is just
freaking idyllic so hopefully
that will continue for you guys and
hopefully the world doesn't fall apart
and hopefully we're all at peace for the
rest of our time on earth you guys can
follow me on twittermines.com and sour
patch lids
as well as sarah patrick's get the sour
patch kids now that's right now it makes
oh my gosh you just figured it out it
took him all the way through the show i
stock the sour pitch kids on our table
because i am sour patch that makes sense
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you